what is up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're going
to talk about the truth we're going to
get candid with it sorry I got a little
bit of a throat issue going on here so
keep me in prayers but I'm here with my
beautiful wife and co-host Aubrey it's
good to have you here as you are here
every time this our show uh she's
actually gonna be talking about a crazy
subject the dark origins of androgyny so
MH somebody out there doesn't know what
androgyny is what would you say
androgyny is it's being neither female
or male being neutral or non-binary okay
I was going to say today we hear that
term non-binary fluid all these things
that are just pure confusion Babylon
this is what the Bible said is going to
happen in these days it's going to be
back to the days of Babylon when Babylon
literally means confusion and to me I
look at the world I'm like this is the
most confusing state of the world I've
ever seen in my own life time where you
don't know what gender you are you're
not allowed to say if you say the wrong
pronoun you could be in trouble uh also
things like it's okay to mock
Christianity but not certain minority
people groups and there's just a lot of
confusion in the world MH but I'm
interested to see what you have on this
because you know I do believe that Satan
the the God of this world he's trying to
depopulate the world he there's all
these fake misinformation stuff that's
out there fake news like that the world
is overpopulated and they show things
like New York City and you know the
crosswalks and they show China and all
these really compacted like New York's
small I mean you look on the map it's
tiny up there uh we just flew to um well
we flew to Bolivia and we got to fly
over some some space over the world and
when you're flying over the United
States you see a lot of empty space you
know I just went to Wyoming we drove to
Wyoming and there's a lot of empty space
out there overpopulation is a lie it's
not true it's it's a propaganda
to really introduce depopulation
introduce making abortion trendy making
or maybe not trendy but acceptable um
actually yeah trendy I've seen a woman
wearing a t-shirt that's like I've had
five abortions and she was just like
proud of it um you know making your
cutting your genitals off or mutilating
your genitalia where you can't procreate
um the LGBT lifestyle making that trendy
all these things are agendas to
depopulate and saying things like
climate change overpopulation all these
things really kind of justify the reason
to do that but really we know that Satan
hates Humanity we are image of God uh he
hates
seeing us be the image of him and he
wants to do he wants to pervert
everything that God's ever made God made
sex god made gender God made men and
women beautifully different to where
they are perfectly compatible they
complete each other you know you can't
repopulate the world you can't populate
the world without male and female
together like man if it was just man on
the earth he really couldn't populate
for one
and there's only so much he can do you
know he's a hard worker he's strong but
he doesn't have really the nurturing
side and all these things that the woman
does I can't breastfeed a child uh I
can't give birth and a woman can't do
that without the man so we really
together we complete each other we make
this circle of life and we can create
life and Satan wants to stop that but
you know that's what I know that's what
I think is happening with these Trends
and things like that you know I didn't
deal with this stuff when I was in
elementary school and middle school and
even in high school you know there was
some some people that started to like
come out as homosexual and stuff like
that but never like this gender identity
stuff that we deal with now and um it's
really propagated through the media to
make it trendy and it's just confusing
it's confusing a lot of people and um
but you have done a lot of research like
she always does she digs deep when it
comes to finding out what it what is the
root of all this stuff what is the root
of rman or what is the root of whatever
these different things secret societies
and all this stuff that's in our world
today where did it originate
from and you actually got to the bottom
of where the root of androgyny came from
it's not just a trend that's that we're
dealing with today this goes way back
and it actually has some spiritual
connotations to it so I'm interesting
I'm interested to see what you have for
us yes well good because you just
introduced it pretty well we're just
going to walk ourselves straight through
history right from Biblical times
awesome and see what happened and
because we think it's new we think we're
the ones dealing with things that got
worse yeah like oh my goodness these
days you can't even you know say the
right pronouns and you you're confused
as to what someone is when you see them
and all this stuff but like you're
saying it's always it's been there
nothing new Under the Sun the Bible says
and we're going to see that so let's
just begin
awesome all right so as I began to
realize this actually encompassed more
than just androgyny not choosing to be a
gender it actually encompassed lgbtq
plus whatever all of the stuff I forget
how many they have now the growing ever
growing acronym yes and so I just had to
put that on the um first slide here
here and let's just begin with
ishar also also known as istar as I have
it spelled there or Anana she's from
Mesopotamia in Samaria
so Mesopotamia would
be more
of I guess what you would
call the Babylonian
era
um maybe I'm wrong but let's just read
through this it says the gala which were
Gala Priests of Anana or Ishtar were a
class of sacred priests dedicated to her
elect created by enki we're gonna want
to know who enki is he's very key in all
of this who per uh created by eny to
perform heart soothing laments they sang
myths in emsol a Southern Southern a
Samaran dialect used it says they sang
hymns hymns they do yes that's right
good catch actually they sang hymns in
emsol a Samaran dialect used for female
god speech and their duties included
presiding over rights healing divination
music charity encountering evil during
eclipses and were well respected in
their
communities wow sex with a Gala was
considered lucky symbolizing Union with
the goddess herself through
transubstantiation now please hold on to
that too I'm going to keep saying this
when we come across key things are going
to keep popping up and we're going to
start creating or connecting the dots
you're going to start putting thread
with a pin to another thread with a pin
okay we're going to see all of it come
to life so I told you to keep an eye out
for en key thank you and
transubstantiation is the next one that
just mentioned now it said sex with a
Gala what is a Gala is it a person
walking around it is it is a
true priest but they're looked at as
gods or no just priests just priests
okay um let's see here they were
respected figures though often embodying
transgender identities so that came
straight from transgender identities in
the ancient Mediterranean lgb.org wow
so this isn't you know a lot of people
would think we're trying to make
something out of nothing or this is our
own agenda or something that's straight
from
lgbti LGBT yeah yeah so they're telling
you the the
history that's good yeah it that's the
kind of sources I'm going to show all
the way through yeah so there no bias
right yeah all right so their unique
position both revered and feared stemmed
from their ability to transcend
conventional boundaries embodying Divine
and demonic traits wow demonic traits
yes that comes from that paper there
androgyny the Pagan sexual ideal which I
actually suggest everyone go
read but that's all I'm going to say U
it says some Gala were cisgender women
or married with Children others were
transgender or non-binary not limited to
A's cult
a notable example is a statuette from
Mary interesting that they would mention
Mary Mary with an eye with an eye
dedicated to a Nana named after ER nansi
male but depicting female
features so here we have Mary being
brought into it it already said that it
was in Nana's
cult yeah and we're starting to see that
there's proof that that was a male
having female features yeah okay so this
is already this transgender well I'm I'm
already thinking I don't know if you're
going to go there probably but like the
BFF you know
I make your point yeah you see those
statues popping up everywhere and it's
an occult image but it's a goat-headed
being sitting in the Lotus position with
one arm up one arm down representing As
Above So Below but it's got female
breast and a phallic um caducus staff in
its lap so representing the male and the
female if that image right there could
be enough to show you like this
lifestyle or whatever is satanic I just
smile because that's such a good point
it's gonna be a part of all this awesome
even though I didn't include it so good
job good awesome yep all right so
um then
another comment on them is that the
gaya's reputation ex extended to same
seex activities per perhaps influenced
by the literal meaning of their name
Gala which means forgive me for saying
so but penis Das anus that's insane
because I was wondering what Gala meant
because I'm thinking of this event that
all the celebrities go to called the Met
Gala right do you bring that up no but I
was hoping you would explain or make
that point as well yeah I don't well at
the Met Gala all these celebrities who
are the American Idols of our world they
gather together they're celebrated
everybody's taking pictures and they are
decked out and ironically in well the
last one that I saw was this religious
apparel dressed like popes which the
pope his attire is deeon that hat he
wears that tall hat when just look up
Pope Deon you'll see that that hat is a
fish head with its mouth open and the
cape goes down deeon had a fish head on
his head head and the cape was the skin
of the fish MH and that's all the pope
is doing um but at the Met Gala penis
anus Gathering of these American Idols
who are dressed in this religious Garb
this is the same thing that's been going
on for all throughout history Babylonian
times it's happening today right wow
it's G to get a little more involved of
course but yes okay so second sentence
there over time the roles of Gala
expanded to include men either in
training or newly castrated gatur so we
see that castration becomes a part of
this highlighting their diverse gender
identities across Samaran and Assyrian
contexts this comes straight from the
queer story files of
blogspot.com well another lgbtq
blog or something yeah it also says in
mythological accounts a Nana is rescued
from the underworld of two oh by two
beings described as neither male nor
female various classes of priests in
Samaran and Assyrian religion occupied
alternative gender roles distinct from
those of men and women so those are
actual pictures the statues I have um
depicted right there are these priests
they're wearing skirts or dresses they
have full well full beard on the right
they um short hair
and I don't know weird things in their
hands um but those are
these the two beings that um were
neither male nor female that's them yes
these are the priests somewhat like
Burton Ernie or something I don't know I
question everything now you know it's
like I I even found stuff that says that
the Simpsons the characters of The
Simpsons date back to some Egyptian
ancient Egyptian thing they found
hieroglyphs what's interesting is that
it's newly found so it's not like Matt
groaning the director of the creator of
The Simpsons saw these things and said
oh I should make a character based on
that he made the characters and now
recently Bart
Lisa Marge have all been discovered I
mean Marge has a green dress blue hair
standing
up uh and and they look identical but
just now recently discovered so how does
that happen does The Simpsons always
predict everything I believe Matt
groaning being a 33 degree Freemason is
getting Knowledge from the spirit world
and he was inspired by the Demon World
to make these characters and now it's
coming out that these were Egyptian gods
and things like that we're being
entertained by The Simpsons was like my
favorite show of all time for a while
oh okay so here's where we focus on eny
his story comes alive a little bit you
mentioned the caducus it's all over
there yeah um of course that became
his
symbol um he is the highest God of
What's called the Anunnaki and we're
going to explore that further yeah so
just hold on to that nugget okay but
because he was known for the serpents he
actually has what's called when you're
follower of him a Brotherhood of the
serpent which is Freemasonry yeah wow
the Brotherhood of the serpent yes wow
and of course we know right there it's
on there the medical staff yeah um we
have the DNA strands um double helix we
have the UN
symbol we have the serpent going up the
spine of the chakras that's the
Kundalini Yoga yep we got all of it
there um this has to do also with
reptilians or as not Gods that's why
very on the very left of that picture
they have what looks like eagle or
reptilian Gods um with oh okay in the in
the black and white image yes the black
and white one and interesting that
there's like a tree going on in between
those two
reptiles always a tree ever since back
to the Garden of Eden yes and um on the
very right that's also a tree that is
that's the anunaki tree of Le of Life
sorry and below that is the cabala tree
of
life and we have the Egyptian ones
underneath that and the Babylonian one
in the
middle but en is known for the streams
of Water of Life he's known as the god
of creation water um wisdom
craftsmanship and mischief and Magic wow
so this would be like saying that he is
God the
father and so um I guess stepping back
one one footstep we are going to see
going back to the tree of life that was
called in his story The Mery tree the
Mery tree what does that sound like
Merry Christmas tree yeah yeah we did
touch on that a little bit in the
previous episode which was about um Bale
who is Bale or who's the Rainman yeah
which is Bale MH um often brought up in
rap and hip hop and just a lot of things
but you did touch on this tree aspect
that we've seen all through history
these phallic symbols and Sun worship
and all this and a lot of times people
have this in their home at a certain
time of the year December 25th which
also is a a date really significant in
paganism for the birth of nimrod and um
so yeah it's very interesting but I
think it's it's all really a counterfeit
of the Garn ofine and the tree of
knowledge Satan keeps because we see it
in in all kinds of entertainment too
we've analyzed anime and movies and
cartoons and things like that and a lot
of them that have this Gnostic theme
have this tree aspect the tree of
knowledge and so I believe that's what
it is anyway that's a reference to the
tree of knowledge they call it the Tree
of
Life um maybe it is the Tree of Life
maybe it represents the tree of life
because God is keeping us from getting
to that
tree it says lest we eat of that fruit
and become imort immortal Sinners God
doesn't want us to be in a world where
you know rapists and murderers and liars
and thieves live on
forever the the wages of sin is death
and the gift of God is everlasting life
and none of us will get that gift until
we receive Christ we repent of our sins
and Christ returns and gives us
immortality it says that we will put on
immortality and then those who keep the
Commandments of God will have the right
to the Tree of Life says in Revelation
right but Satan wants to get to that
tree he wants to live forever he wants
others to believe that they can have
access to that tree of life too
right so that's we're gonna I don't know
we're going to expand on that a lot
awesome because this is going to focus
Fus a lot on serpents
somehow um but this is where the idea of
a third gender came in with en key one
that does not conform to being one
gender or the other but a neutral
gender so going to this this is how we
know enki's tree of life started being
depicted unfortunately this is the um
probably the most occult and nasty
depiction because this is how they do
their rituals which are
um in cabala tree of life and as you see
with the blue
lady um I'll just read what it says
there even though it's in Hebrew it has
the names given to us in English it says
doth the upper
Eden oh which is like her neck
region and then there's Yad it says the
lower Eden which is her womb or womb gal
yes and then when we go to the middle
picture that is actually uh in German
but it's all about the occult things
there and we see the elements first
thing in the
bubble if you notice though there's the
sun yeah on the top everything relates
to a part of the
body and then we have the circle below
which has the planets it has certain
statuses um that I'm not going to get
into for one it's really gross and I
don't want to talk about that but two
two let's look if we can at
um on the
right the very right hand corner in the
bottom of this picture we have this
image of um it's kind of like a horned
God okay that's or a horned um you
talking about this one no oh no it's the
middle image still okay that says Rebus
on it and Rebus means
male and female
combined okay that's really all I want
people to know right here you can zoom
in on that oops you go back won't okay
be able to unfortunately but um the
image on the very right is very very
interesting it has at each stage it
actually has what this region is what
God in the Egyptian world you are
worshiping and then at it's all written
there with the demons that are involved
Lucifer baffet be elub the degrees
related to Freemasonry it has those
names on this yes and it has the demons
related if I didn't say that already and
um that you're working towards this
point it actually has right on there it
has on here somewhere the Rebus and
that's it should be where this wolfhead
guy is so this is actually the pentagram
if you notice all the symbols down
below yeah the hexagram six points yep
these are different ways that they would
show this for the male and the female
which is supposedly a chaos order out of
chaos right the two becoming one to
create this great Union and
Enlightenment so I know that's a lot
just take it in but um that's really all
I want to show with that it's just
really gross the way they're depicting
it and as we break down en key and the
Brotherhood of the serpent which was
Freemasonry remember that M um this
snake or caducus is linked with Satan of
course who may be identified with eia or
enki he was known by either name in the
re religion of
Satanism which embodies Hidden Truths
now this comes from confessions of an
Illuminati Volume
2 it says it's used as DNA we already
said that a symbol for medical
professionals as well since ancient
Mesopotamia the caducus presents
presented two serpents intertwined
supposed to be the central nervous
system around a staff the spinal column
with the wings called the swan on either
side or the two hemispheres of the brain
with the circle in the center
representing the pineal gland or the
central sun and psychic Center
within now just the going talk about the
pineal gland a little okay I think we
should just recognize that it's called
pineal or pine all yeah Pine is going to
come in like a pine cone yeah yeah it
also symbolizes the Kundalini
energy second point there is the ancient
Egyptian pharaohs were thought to be
aliens or space Travelers or wannabe
Travelers who built their pyramids for
myth mythical purposes
these are connected to alleged pyramids
on Mars and other astronomical bodies
possibly for
navigation so way back then this eny
anunaki story of him being this God
setting up this
structure it already includes pyramids
strange yeah the
serpent but travelers from space yeah
because when you really think about I
already mentioned this on another show
like I don't even buy into any of space
travel stuff I don't believe we went to
the moon or have a Mars remot remote
control car driving around on Mars but
Lucifer is a being that fell from the
heavens mhm so when you talk about like
worshiping beings from other worlds and
you know other planets or whatever out
there you're talking about demons these
are the beings that fell from the
heavens and you know they're bound to
Earth but
they impersonate
travelers from other worlds yeah because
I can't really leave here I don't
believe um I know in the Book of Job
Satan presented himself to to God in
heaven but I'm pretty sure at some point
after that he has become bound to this
earth it says that he's the God of this
world and all these things right I don't
think he can travel around anymore like
that right but he can you know he is
called the prince of the power of the
air it says that there will be signs and
wonders in the heavens um it talks about
Miracle working demons and all these
things in the
skies and so what they're doing these
fallen angels are creating a mythology
about themselves nobody would worship
demons or Fallen Angels even why would
you worship a angel that fell you know
right but if Satan can twist our
understanding just a little bit if he
can just tweak no we're not Fallen
Angels we're not evil we didn't fall
from Heaven we are actually visitors
from other worlds and we're here to help
you m we want to actually save your
planet uh is his lie that many people
all through history have been falling
for yeah I don't know this just
encompasses so
much so yeah without further Ado I got
introduced into the anaki stuff when I
got sucked into the Ancient Aliens
program on the History Channel yeah so
it also says this ancient teaching was
passed up through history through a
variety of secret brotherhoods such as
Rosicrucianism Freemasonry and the
Illuminati their thought to still be
around probably doing something
involving the Rothchilds the
international Jewish conspiracy
Freemasons or lizard people walking
about so this is not my uh language or
my quote here at all it actually came
from um an
ult Source It also says that snake
symbolism can be found everywhere in the
world that's a fact we can but it
indicates the influence of the
Brotherhood I just want to say that over
and over again because and that's kind
of what I'm doing I'm just building a
case yeah point after point of these
different sources or the same Source
actually showing credibility to that all
right so it says obviously in the
caducus OR staff of Hermes so now it's
actually known as the staff of Hermes
that's what I've known it as uhhuh it's
used as an emblem of Physicians but also
in many other places such as the RX on
prescription bottles which means Rex
which links to the Eye of Horus which is
a symbol of the Brotherhood of the snake
W wonder if there's any link to the
T-Rex you hear that word Rex you know we
always associate it with dinosaurs and
stuff like in I don't know if there's a
cartoon and somebody has a
little um pet Dino it's like oh it's rex
or
whatever so I I mean yeah there's so
much occultist in our culture you know
and we don't even know about it until
you dig dig deep and find this stuff yep
so it says this was originally the
symbol for the anoi Syrian Creator God
IIA or enki was the chief of The
Magicians the one who knows so pay
attention to the one who knows as well
okay and was Infamous for being the
serpant of the Garden of Eden who
created life forms in test tubes half a
million years ago wow with his half
sister nin harag at the at the
suggestion of his son
Marduk to create humans to be the
workers for the gods they seeded the
Tree of Life which Bears pine
cones okay which is a symbol of the
royal anunaki family in enki so this is
what we've been talking about this this
Gnostic idea that the serpent in the
Garden of Eden actually created humans
in test tubes not not from the dust of
the earth and all that uh and this idea
that the the Tree of Life In the Garden
of Eden was a pine tree that's right and
so now we're starting to see why do you
why do you bring in the evergreen tree
in your house during Christmas time when
it relates to the birth of nimrod and
all these things the evergreen tree what
I know about it is it's a symbol of Sun
worship because it never dies through
the winter you know these people that
worship the sun when the sun would when
it was cold they were they thought oh is
the sun leaving us is it ever going to
come back but this green tree that's
ever green was a symbol of promise that
the sun will return when all the other
trees are dead right yeah there's a lot
of uh symbolism with that pine cone and
it representing the pineal gland of the
brain the frontal lobe um this is what
you know new agers and everything they
want to open up their third eye and all
this stuff I don't believe in that
terminology but I do believe that
there's something to it there I mean
they've they've shown it U scientists
have seen it and stuff that there's this
part of your brain that looks like a
skinned over eye or something and it
resembles a pine cone all these things
and some people believe that fluoride in
the water is calcifying that part of
your brain and that part of your brain
is the Discerning part the the front
frontal seat of your mind when you're
looking at information and trying to
recognize is it true and discernment and
all these things and so when you watch
fast-paced entertainment and things like
that it front it shuts down the frontal
lobe of your brain to where you're not
Discerning what is this information I'm
watching it's mindless entertainment at
that point you're just and that's what
people tell you you guys are digging too
deep this stuff it's just Mindless
entertainment it feels like that because
your brain is shut off but those
messages are going past that now you're
watching this entertainment and whatever
message is put in that piece of media is
now bypassing your ability to um discern
and everything and now you're just
accepting it as like well this is M you
know that's why we see life imitates art
I believe life imitates art not the
other way around people say art imitates
life but I think things that are you
know if you don't if you could I could
present a script to Hollywood and it
could be the best story ever and they
could say okay we like it but they're
not going to do it just like they we
like it but we want you to change this
add this put this type of character we
need some representation this and that
right they're going to there's an agenda
we must include these things you're not
going to get the right the movie and so
the more that we see this stuff the more
we believe this is normal right when you
see two men together your whole life
like you know kids growing up in this
generation they or you see oh some
people are male some people are female
some people are non-binary when that's
all you've known your whole life even if
it's just on TV that becomes the norm
and it then life imitates the art yes
I don't know why I went on that rent
okay no it was talking about the pineal
gland and and discernment and all this
stuff but um that's what I believe that
that frontal lobe pineal gland is about
discernment and that's why God wants us
to have sober mind do not drink alcohol
and and mess your mind up don't you're
not sober anymore don't smoke don't do
all these things that intoxicate your
mind and watch this crap on TV that
shuts some frontal over your brain down
and and you become like it you know I
was setting a wicked thing before my
eyes we don't we don't want to be
transformed into those things because
you you basically you know you are what
you eat type thing you are who you
become who you have friends you become
like them and it rubs off on you and so
we need to be careful about what we
watch and we need to have a sober mind
MH yeah there's a lot
to that like you're
unraveling um but someone who's probably
asking the question how does enki
connect to this androgyny thing again he
was The God Who made supposedly these
gas these priests to sing these hymns
and these laments and do this kind of
priesthood to Anana okay and I said he's
kind of it's like saying that's father
God the Father in Heaven he's like the
almighty so he's the one that kind of
blessed them into that position or
something okay mhm so it's really messed
up um we're going to follow him through
some pictures here um it says enki walks
out of the water to the land extended
attended by his messenger isud now if
you look at the first Circle the very
top this is isud who
has two faces looking in opposite
directions so this is the first time we
see Duality that's another name for when
you are actually
exhibiting both genders within one
person okay the two- fa
yes and you'll see that many gods do
this this is where Walter VI opened my
eyes first thing to to this because
every God whether it's Bale whether it's
Marduk whether it's Venus Cupid whatever
they all eventually you can go and find
that each of them has one
face that
is I guess normal
and and the other that's not and it's
two-faced meaning that one's supposedly
female and one's male wow so I um but
this is where it started with en key and
um how it ties into Freemasonry it
actually has a picture here it says it's
on the very top right eny stands with
the gods and the
initiate the Water of Life flowing into
the laboratory glassware indicates alel
circulation so here we're getting
straight into the ult Alchemy involved
here to create life and they're all
holding hands so that tree of life can
come
together um down
below it shows these reptile be beings
handing the pine cone or water liquid
blood of life to the bio engineered
humans cuz humans are supposed to be
known as hybrid species
yeah created by the anaki yes now the
very last image here um I kind of went
in a circle at the very bottom of um the
left corner it says the creation of the
first human is depicted here that tree
the human sitting on the god the God's
lap you can usually see that the god um
is there because they have the horns on
yeah um it says laboratory vessels
symbolize the bloodline and the Tree of
Life
so there's proof and even their drawings
yeah of all of
this so I knew and I wanted to know
myself what does anunaki
mean reading the term um this definition
in yellow it says the term anunaki
refers to those who from Heaven came to
Earth all right there should be Bells
going off already and it often is
translated as those who descend or
princely
Offspring often depicted as reptilians
coming from space to find gold now
please latch on to the word gold we're
going to talk about gold a lot okay and
it's not necessarily the kind of gold
you're thinking
but enlightened with mysterious or
secret knowledge they are the one who
knows or those who are enlightened
Masters now enlightened Masters that's
what I'm going to explain right now we
have ascended masters usually in yoga
yep and brahmanism and all these other
gods that's what they
mean yeah I mean that's not all that
they mean but so you have Satan
basically what they're saying you have
the demons and Satan coming down
descending out of heaven when they got
kicked out of heaven yeah to Earth and
now they're the ones who know now know
what evil yeah that's what I was going
to say you know sometimes we we've read
a lot of the Bible we know the stories
and everything and so we see something
like this and the alarm Bells go off but
maybe somebody out there doesn't know
the stuff as you know these stories as
much as we do which is why you know we
see something like calina yoga and it's
like oh you're inviting the serpent to
your crown chakra it's like no you don't
want the serpent to go to your brain
because we know who the serpent is yeah
but if you never heard the Bible at all
you might just be like oh yeah a serpent
is wise and you know whatever and I want
to be like that
but when you talk about these beings
that were reptilian likee that descended
from the heavens with wisdom that's
exactly that was the serpent in the
garden he was cast out of Heaven to
Earth in Eden he said eat this fruit and
your eyes will be open you'll be like
God knowing good and evil and and his
lie his deception is that God doesn't
want you to he's hiding something from
you he doesn't want you to know things
he doesn't want you to have knowledge
but really God was trying to keep us
from knowing evil MH he didn't want any
he didn't want to keep anything good
from us but he didn't want us to know
about things like death and all the
disgusting things that happen in this
world but once they ate of that tree
then we were introduced to all the evil
and death and things in the world right
so that should have meant a lot like
you're saying it might not but it it
really had a lot there that was packed
in just the
definition um um and
that came from Samaran origins.com so
this is history this is actually a
history place I don't know what you want
to call it but yeah uh history website
of pagan origins and things yep so the
next thing that it says here is the
anunaki are chiefly mentioned in
literary texts each member of the
anunaki had his or her own individual
cult interesting
interesting separate from the others
similarly no representation of the anoi
as a complete group have yet been
discovered are the de demons really
going to show that their their
connections to one another very openly
no they have disguises they have to keep
the deception going yeah so yeah
although a few depictions of the two or
three individual members together have
been identified they were thought to
possess extraordinary powers and were
often envisioned as being of tremendous
physical size wow hm
yeah deities were almost always depicted
wearing horned caps we see the music
artists we see celebrities we see all
kinds of people when they come out on
stage wearing horns yeah people are
drawing that it is actually meant to
mean that you are one of these gods of
Anunnaki you hold power of enki the
almighty
God kind of yeah but the Pagan one
flipped up you know flipped upside
down as your god of power
wow it's just weird yeah and you have
the Vikings right you have the Vikings
you have um Celtic horns I guess yeah
well I I uh when I was in Wyoming it was
Bike Week biker week or whatever and
these guys are riding around with those
like bkings a bunch of them were wearing
that mhm you know I don't know what what
we think like oh it just looks cool or
whatever but that's how Satan does this
to us he he uses deception on every
level God never uses deception or Force
it's always love it's always that still
Small Voice knocking on the door of your
heart please open the door so I can come
in but Satan is just like oh isn't this
cool and trendy and you should do this
because you can be cool you should wear
horns on your head or
yep and become uh IES and all this stuff
too oh wow okay I'm going to unpackage
that a little bit okay because what I
haven't
mentioned until now is that en key is
also known as either half human and half
fish oh or goat and half human wow I
don't know how they got the two random
ones but they that's what he's known for
that's like pan yes so pan was a or
you're saying Inky was
uhhuh okay so Inky has
different uh ways in which he's depicted
yeah but we all know mostly the baffet
or Satan or Lucifer or however you want
to put it the devil is baffet yeah and
the horns as he's depicted as a goat
that's what you're doing you're actually
worshiping or venerating when you wear
the horns or you draw yourself horns
whatever you want to say you're kind of
like this is my God is so popular right
now too who was it some oh it's a friend
of mine who's a art teacher in a college
and he says that everybody's right now
it's like a fad or whatever that people
they draw these anime style people and
they all often have horns they're always
adding horns on them
mhm it's pretty messed up like I went
through my phase of drawing dark things
but it wasn't I
was purposely seeking like Darkness like
Marilyn Manson The ult all that type of
stuff but now it's just like it's trendy
this is what all the kids are doing so
they're paring it you know and for some
reason everybody has horns this is a
such a dark
Generation Um I was listening to
somebody I don't remember who it was it
wasn't a Christian it was a podcast and
they said this just stop being so
rebellious like they were talking about
the whole like I think it's like the
pronouns and everything they're saying
it's just rebellion in general and I was
like this is interesting to hear from
somebody that's not even a Christian
that we live in the age of rebellion in
whatever
way um where it's just pure confusion
and rebellious and that's what the the
Bible talks about the age of lawlessness
there's no laws no laws of nature no
laws of physics no laws of bi biology
you know it's just whatever anything
goes Lawless
m w man um so we have a lot more still I
really did a thorough job on this so um
just bear with me so we didn't get to
finish that last sentence there um
actually start again with deities were
almost always depicted wearing horned
caps consisting of up to seven
superimposed pairs of oxh horns now I'm
sure that actually starts looking like a
pentagram once you super impose certain
horns all right um at least that's my
guess but the last sentence says they
were also sometimes depicted wearing
clothes with elaborate decorative gold
and silver ornaments sewed into
them that doesn't have too much
significance to me yet
but um the next paragraph says the
earliest known usage of the term anunaki
came from inscriptions written during
the reign of gudia at least that's how
I'm going to say say it and the third
dynasty
of is in the Bible how yes we have ER
and the calans and the calans are also
known as Babylonians okay so then you
think of nimrod and the Tower of
Babel and Babylon that's where your mind
should go like that era that time that's
the culture we're talking about it was
very evil right yeah that's when God had
to scatter everybody because
the people United as one they all had
one language and the Bible says that
they all have one language and this they
think to do like this wicked thing build
this Tower to
Heaven um who knows whatever other
things they were doing but we are in a
time like that again where thanks to the
internet and
Technology um all our languages are one
I mean I get a message and an email or
on a YouTube comment it's not even in
English I can just simply tap the button
that says translate and there it is MHM
There's No Boundaries now with language
you can even there's apps where you can
talk into your phone and then it will
repeat it in Chinese or whatever you
could just walk around the street be
like hey uh how you doing today and
it'll say in Chinese and then they say
it back um so we're really going back to
that day yes and very much so we're
going to see so this guy during the
third dynasty of
udia it says in his earliest text the
term is applied to the most powerful and
important deities in the Samaran
Pantheon the descendants of the sky God
on this group of deities probably
included the seven gods who
decree H okay an or an N Lil and key
ners Nana U and
Anana so all of a sudden it lists all of
them
yeah so here we have anunaki actually
being it's actually being admitted that
it was a part of the caldan or
Babylonian religion basically yeah in
their inscriptions it was one of their
ancient
texts that's the point that is there but
when we follow through it says although
certain deities are described as members
of the anaki no complete list of the
names of all the anaki has survived they
are usually only referred to as a
cohesive group in literary texts
originally the anunaki appear to have
been he Heavenly deities with immense
powers in the poem it's interesting that
they have this please listen up in the
poem enki and the world order
wow eny is Satan and Satan wants a new
world order uhhuh the anaki do homage to
enki so all the other lesser gods of the
anunaki pay homage to
eni and they sing hymns of Praise In
honor and take up their dwellings among
the people of Sumer so now all of a
sudden you have them manifesting as
humans among the people of Sumer wow
which is also a Biblical Town
interesting yeah we know in the uh in
the Bible it says that Angels can't
appear as humans I mean often times it
even just says it like that like we know
that when Jesus ascended into the cloud
after his death he resurrected and he
ascended into the clouds and and I was
watching them it says two men in white
apparel appeared and said what are you
gazing at or whatever those were Angels
but it said two men often times the
Bible would just say two men uh
when two angels and I believe it was
Jesus it doesn't say it because jesus'
name isn't mentioned in the Old
Testament but uh Abraham was approached
by three men and he was feeding them and
everything and they were talking about
how Sodom gomorah was going to be
destroyed mhm and he started pleading
with the Lord it says so I believe that
was Jesus but he was pleading like are
you going to destroy the righteous with
the wicked and all these things point is
Angels appear as men yep and I believe
that that works for good and bad Angels
fallen and unfallen Angels yes uh I
believe that Satan and his unfallen
angels have the ability to shape shift
we know that he appeared as a serpent M
we know that he they they appear as
these alien beings we know that he can
appear as an angel of Light so the Bible
does tell us that he has the ability to
change form and I believe he can appear
as as a human too yes so where were we
all right the same composition twice
states that the anoi decree the fates of
mankind now we just saw the seven gods
who
decree that's the connection there so
there's the seven gods they just
mentioned they just tied that in in the
um paragraphs above now all of a sudden
it actually says those that decree the
fates of
mankind in Egyptian kdic or Coptic
religions or Egyptian
Orthodoxy uh the God Thoth I hope they
don't say it that way and an new are
highly respected Gods above others this
would seem to be
Ani really yeah strange though that the
anunaki are said to have become or
materialize as the god th during his
Reign and become or influence the ruling
monarchs and government officials as
they take leadership in the world so
that their direction for the world is
carried out whoa so these beings are
interacting with the governments of the
world I believe that's happening right
now we I mean we've never lived in a
time as we have now where there's actual
meetings going on saying yes we had
communication with non-human
intelligences the military the leaders
of this world are telling us that
they've that they have been
communicating for years since the 30s
with non-human intelligence beings From
Another Dimension you know they they
even say we don't want to say they're
alien we don't know what they are they
possibly be From Another Dimension I
believe they are From Another Dimension
and we are communicating with them and
when you read Revelation it says that
Satan is trying to round up the
militaries of the world it says three
unclean spirits like frogs interesting
description when you look at an alien
gray it look like a frog
but it says that they are going to the
kings of the earth which would be the
leaders and military leaders and
presidents and all these and uniting the
militaries of the world to fight Christ
I believe that's what we're I believe
that's what's happening I believe that's
why we have a space force we're
literally making weapons pointed towards
the heavens preparing to fight Christ
everything what the Bible says is
happening now the militaries of the
world are communicating with these demon
demonic beings fallen angels in
preparation to fight Christ right and
even they don't know what's going on
some of them may be but I believe the
majority of these leaders are deceived
themselves into thinking
that these alien beings are actually
trying to help us that they want to get
rid
of pandemics and climate change and all
this and ultimately they want to help us
fight to save Earth from an evil alien
Invader that's coming yeah and that evil
alien Invader is Christ with all his
angels and so literally you have
Humanity siding with Satan and his
demons to fight Christ and it's all a
huge deception they believe that they're
fighting to save the Earth from
destruction this means though just to
wrap that up that they would actually
material realiz themselves or you
possess if you will every ruling Monarch
that comes on the scene wow to
accomplish what they want so you're
saying that these fallen angels are
actually appearing as men that are in
high places and politics and everything
yeah I believe it yeah I mean I've seen
some of these people who just look so
wicked his Roth Childs and the well you
don't have to be I mean de demon
possession is what I'm getting at it's
not like they are manifesting
manifesting and host bodies or whatever
um that's not what I'm getting at I'm
not they don't have to look ugly and
scary either can look like Beyonce right
but I just think that um people in high
places usually have open themselves up
to Satan and his demons heavily yeah
we'll we'll see some of that a little
bit but um they usually have to carry
out lots of these rituals that in the
cult world and work their way up the
degree the ladders of degrees and all of
that stuff you have to be involved in
the occult but the occult is in the form
in the guise of the Brotherhood of
Freemasonry and everybody just thinks oh
whatever free the LOD yeah
just Boys Club whatever yeah Shriners
they do good for people they give them
Wheelchairs and stuff you so anyway um
yeah they really accomplished their
their
goal oh
no all right all right we got to get
back to what technical difficulties you
were on
yeah okay let's see if it will yes okay
so in the ktic faith it just mentioned
that and I watched this huh oh I just
said ktic I was just reading that word
yes ktic they also have the cabala Tree
of Life there but this is claimed to not
be the cabala but the Egyptian Tree of
Life wow every culture has a tree life
yes and this woman I was watching her um
um her YouTube video there what is the
purpose of life I didn't really get to
the purpose I just wanted to see what
she did and what I realized is that she
uh gave a drink offering and she began
to bless all the elements Wind Fire Air
um Spirit whatever and then she went
into different gods an new Anubis all of
these
things and and Nana Diana you know what
I mean you're just listening basically
to pretty much she is putting all of the
different things together Jupiter Mars
so the planets the gods the elements
she's doing High witchcraft Y and she's
pouring out a libation a drink offering
every time she says this to Mother Earth
the universe the men you know what I
mean
wow everything that you could have said
she said yeah and that's that's really
how Satan Works he has a different
flavor for everybody for me I was
interested in the occult so the dark
things Ouija boards Sarah cars all that
he got that flavor if you're not into
that oh I got new age look at this it's
all light and love and colors and
ascended masters and then if you're not
into that then what about this um you
know I've noticed that a lot
of black people like African-Americans
and stuff they are kind of gravitating
towards Egyptian yes and root of like
ancestor worship and all these type
things because of propaganda like the
Black Panther movie and all those so
this ktic Faith claims that if you are
black skinned you have this magic within
you it is inherent within you to have
the power of the Gods yeah yep and they
call Christianity the white man religion
and it's not white at all it originates
from Israel it's it's Israeli it's not
white and in true israelies are dark
skinned I mean they're really dark
that's a whole lie in itself that
Christianity is The White Man's religion
but Satan has duped so many cultures yes
so that anyway made me think that people
probably a lot of people haven't heard
of what the ktic faith is it so this is
what it is just so that others know it's
um kemeticism or Egyptian neopaganism
so get a load of that um is a modern
Revival of ancient Egyptian religion
characterized by its focus on nature
ethical living and ancestral veneration
it seeks to restore the worship of a
wide range of Egyptian gods and
goddesses emphasizing the
interconnectedness of all living beings
and the importance of harmonious
relationships with nature the universe
the great mother and they claimed to be
the original yoga gurus who taught the
Indians how as Egypt came before India
okay so they're saying yeah we are the
actual descendants of the Egyptians and
we are the ones who came up with yoga
yeah the Egyptians yeah so practitioners
celebrate festivals engage in rituals
involving offerings and use significant
symbols like the ank the Eye of Horus
and the deed pillar which represents
life protection and stability I'm
guessing that's a phallic symbol like an
obelisk of some sort the religion
incorporates reincarnation and an
afterlife aiming for Spiritual
Enlightenment and unity with the Divine
divination magic and rituals incantation
and ritualistic prayer play integral
Parts roles in Daily practices alongside
Sun worship and the veneration of
elements such as the Earth Wind Fire and
Air kemeticism recognizes no gender
boundaries here's where that comes in
and maintains an open and inclusive
approach to his teachings and
practices um now I mentioned this
because when I first learned about
kemeticism I came across a YouTube video
of a male a man dressed as a woman an
Egyptian goddess okay he had a full
beard and full Egyptian eye makeup and
all of the bracelets and everything and
he called himself the goddess wow and
that's what I've actually um going to
refer to back on the slide here is it
says as they
ascend they actually take on the title
god or goddess wow yeah I just want to
kind of bring a reminder here what we're
even talking about we're not just like
digging into
the history of every occult God and all
that we get into the origins of
androgyny transgenderism all these
alternate Lifestyles and we're seeing it
where uh there's no no boundary of
genders and yeah this is getting
interesting yeah so as they progress in
their spiritual knowledge a formal
priesthood exists within the community
consisting of individuals who have
undergone specific training initiation
and initiation to act as intermediaries
between the gods and
followers
interesting so that's their stance on
gender basically you get to see that and
that's a a definition for you let's not
play that um video okay so as it gets
deeper in the cult of Anana it wasn't
just the gala we have other different
ranks of transgenderism and androgyny
going on okay let's look back at the
slide right it says individuals
associated with the cold of Anana and
her cult members and Priests were known
for their androgyny and blurring or
destroying the gender binary the gender
blurring members of her cult have often
been included in poems and dedications
written for her often with a Nana
personally transforming the gender of
her devotees wow one such example is the
ply ply a group of cultic performers in
Anana Samarian festivals the name py is
referenced with the passionate Anana
it's some kind of scroll or or poem or
something in relation to an individual
named plyy who is transformed by Anana
they are raised as women when when doing
this and the Samarian for young woman
which is
Kil being used to describe them and
Anana blesses them handing them a spear
as if she were a man and renames them
plyy
from this point forward they are
referred to as a transformed plyy the
samarians did not use gender pronouns
but one interpretation is that through
the blessings of Anana the py py trans
transitioned into a man the fic
connotations of the word spear adds
emphasis so again you can see where I
got that y I have cited it straight from
an academic Source in the
UK It also says trans and non-binary
individual ual were not restricted
solely to The Cult of Anana so now we're
going to expand on this this isn't just
Anana right we've actually seen that in
our other examples just a few of them
but one type of Gala Priestess here we
have a priestess yeah interesting was
the Karu a biological male who wore a
robe that was wait a priestess which was
a male yes so I'm glad you said that
because it's just as confusing as today
right yeah and he wore Rob that was
feminine on one side and masculine on
the other okay the Karu were highly
esteemed in Babylonia in one story of
the of Anana the genderless kugar Karu
were created in order to save Anana from
the underworld however even more
prestigious were the ASU okay all of a
sudden we have the ASU too or the
transsexual priestesses of Anana wow the
ASU underwent ritual castration as part
of a mess or a Divine calling of the
Goddess ritual ceration that stood out
to me so as part of your Devotion to the
goddess yeah called to worship and be a
devote of hers you would do this it says
also the ASU were believed to have been
imbued with great powers of protection
and Fortune Warriors of ancient
Mesopotamia would touch the head of an
ASU before battle believing just this
brief contact would spare them from
danger however the most important role
of the ASU was that of a herud
I don't know if I said that right or
sacred
prostitute the asini were believed to be
the physical incarnation of the Goddess
Anana wow and by Sleeping with an ASU a
follower of inana was essentially
coupling with the goddess herself and
that came from
lgb.org
yes so let's break that down a little
bit I told you about transtition yeah
they didn't use that word but basically
what they're saying is that the sinu
transubstantiate and become Anana and do
you have sex
with them yeah here we go with pronouns
right and it's like you just had
relations with the goddess herself oh
transubstantiation in action so when I
hear that term when I hear that term
trans what it substantiation
substantiation I think of the Catholic
Church we're gonna dive into that okay
yeah but that word means that they it's
like a transformation of something from
one thing to another whether it's the
cracker into the literal flesh of Christ
so they're
saying
that you have sex with this goddess and
now you're I don't know somehow Divine
from doing it what I think is
interesting is C ritual
Castor 20 years ago if somebody would
have
mentioned this if they would have been
going into a deep study and saying you
know if you worship this god or goddess
uh followers of them would cut off their
genitalia everybody would say that's
insane who would who in the right mind
would ever do that I would never do that
20 years later we have people cutting
off their genitals and now they're not
even doing they don't even realize
they're doing a form of pagan
ritual but they're doing it because it's
trendy and cool yeah and then regretting
it months and years down the road it's
clever yeah very clever because man so
the first time I presented this we had a
man who had come out of the gay
lifestyle and he had no clue right about
any of this y he lived it for however
long 40 years or something and he was
just blown away by all the actual
ancient and spiritual connections going
on Wow and it gets there's other
spiritual connections with these acts
that we you talked about in the last
video um
you know anal sex and all these things
that yeah are bail worship yeah so every
aspect of the
lgbtq lifestyle Roots back to satanic
practices if you want to get just blunt
with it yeah and I I see even today you
go to those parades the The Pride
parades and you'll see pentagrams you'll
see witchcraft you'll see people dressed
up as the devil you'll see Christ
openly mocked MH and it's like it just
mind it's mindblowing to me that people
don't see the connection and the Occult
and this lgbtq
lifestyle all
right going
ahead we have a God that was actually
known by the samarians and Canaanites as
well as the Egyptians there's overlap
suddenly and once in a while you see
this and it actually starts happening
more
often um she was known as the consort
which means basically spouse of Bale or
lover of
Bale um literally the wife I guess wife
of Bale and her name is anut anat or nut
or n maybe I think it's a n n okay that
sounds more Egyptian yes she's known as
a sky God mostly depicted in in nude
nude human form n was sometimes depicted
in the form of a cow whose great body
formed the sky and Heavens a sycamore
tree so there we go usually another tree
or as a a giant s suckling many piglets
representing the stars or a pot on the
head representing the
uterus um the stars are represented by
piglets yes don't see that but okay it
doesn't show it but it's um the stars in
her abdomen there as the heavens yeah I
do see that I guess that would be that
that life
basally So reading a bit more about her
it says that she was headstrong and
submitted to No One a not is very
similar to cbel yes yep in this way so
now all of a sudden cbel this other
goddess and her were seeing the same
Trend so just pay pay attention to that
a little bit okay she is both young and
attractive but has she's a bearded
Soldier oh is a bearded but is a a
bearded Soldier but is young enough
attractive I uhhuh those don't go
together for me but okay yeah leading
many to believe that she is either
androgynous or bisexual so all of a
sudden we have this it comes on the
scene she thus symbolizes the mystical
and sacred Union of both sexes in one
which is called the sacred spiritual
marriage of the two we're going to look
at that because of which um sorry let's
just go on of which her worshippers
would ritualistically reenact the hyros
gamos that is what that is called this
this ritual hyros gamos is the sacred
spiritual marriage of the two is a
fertility right in
wiah which isn't enacted at belain or
Easter interesting as the great right
they also call it the great right to
become initiated into the third
degree so now they're mentioning
Freemasonry yeah as it relates to
wiccanism
belain means the fire of Bale or Bell no
same name it is passing through the fire
usually jumping through it as a
purification ritual before performing
the sexual act of the great right and
this is what the Bible talks about don't
don't pass through the fire I'm have to
sneeze oh it is indeed the feminist fig
she is the feminist figure in movement
of that time period in stories from
ancient Canan written by Michael kugan
he notes that while a not aard and Aira
appear regularly in these y ugarit myths
none of them have major roles Ashira is
consort of the supreme god l so now they
just have the same goddess and she's not
married to Bale it's l all of a sudden
W the warlike an not is Bale's sister
and his wife so all of a sudden Nimrod
married his mother's sister yeah do you
see how Nimrod really sister is Bale he
created Bale worship and then the story
perpetuated from Nimrod and he
became it became Bale and a KN Bale and
C whatever you know what I mean yeah she
has a furious temper like the Hindu
goddess kie so all of a sudden kie kie
comes on the scene she wears human heads
as a necklace and human hands on a belt
wow in the myth of a quat a non demands
the king give her his bow and arrow made
by the god of crafts when he refuses and
insults her her Vengeance costs him his
life the parallel with ishtar's burned
proposal to Gilgamesh is
striking so there's another overlap this
overlaps the story of Ishtar and
Gilgamesh Gilgamesh that's in the Bible
right yes I was to say I've recognize
that name um yes it is at least that I
know of before wreaking her Vengeance a
not turns to the supreme god L perhaps
for help or permission but presumably he
refuses her because she threatens him
and he lets her
go again there's a parallel with Ishtar
threatening to wreak havoc on the
supreme god
Anu because if the supreme god oh if the
supreme god a new doesn't let her take
revenge on Gilgamesh and with Anana and
a a be okay I'm going to say it that way
a in which and Nana seeks a news
permission to take revenge on the upid
mountain so she seems to have power over
even the most Supreme yeah
interesting all right so as we saw you
might have tuned in before this is Aira
aarte asth Ashira whatever they always
had poles yep and they were known yep
they were known to be gender fluid
because every poll and here's where the
grotesque part comes in
it's any one of these that you want to
choose it's the busted figure it's the
mapole it's the Mery Tree of Life
yeah um it's the just poles there it's
the
tree the Christmas tree the Obelisk
stripper poles
whatever it was
used as a
genderless
um orgy pole let's just put it that way
and so you really don't need to have a
gender and you don't really need to be
specific as to what kind of person you
like because it's all going to happen
that's what they call a pen sexual yeah
you think about why is it called pen
sexual well because it goes back to the
Greek god pen who was the god of sexual
sexual deviant and he was birthed from
an orgy it says so yep it's actually pan
worship and pan is the depiction we have
of Satan these days the horns and the
hoofs and all that
yes
so the Bible talks about these Ashira
estarte and ashra specifically it says
in judges 3:7 the Israelites did evil in
the eyes of the Lord they forgot the
Lord their God and served the Bales and
the
Ashira in Deuteronomy 1621 do not set up
any wooden Asher pole beside the altar
you built to the Lord your God build the
Lord your God so they were doing that I
didn't know it was that Direct in the
Bible yes and as I said there besides
these verses a sheer pulls are mentioned
40 times wow in the Bible so we had a
problem I say we because as a human race
I think we are having a problem yeah
with Ashira and Bale worship obviously
it's just all starting to compound y
okay so going a little bit more into who
she is it says say in the Bible the Iron
Age texts of First Kings 1819 states
that air had prophets entire just as the
Canaanite god Baal had prophets
additionally in 2 Kings 236 it declares
that the priests of Solomon's Temple
brought out all the objects made for
Baal and Ashira and all the hosts of
heaven so they were keeping them yeah in
Solomon's Temple if you don't know that
occultists are always trying to rebuild
or set up an altar that looks like
Solomon's Temple yeah that's that's what
the Freemasons their whole mission is
yes their masonry is building Y and they
want to rebuild Solomon's
Temple um there's myth or legend or may
may or may not be true but that hexagram
the six-pointed star that people
recognize as the Star of David was a
symbol in Solomon's Ring and he would
control demons with it and everything
yeah but
Solomon he was the wisest man in the
Bible um he prayed for wisdom and God
blessed him with that wisdom because it
was like a noble thing he could have
prayed for anything else you know but he
let the he let it get the best of him
and he ended up doing all the things he
wasn't supposed to do marrying for one
married a thousand women and they were
all pagans and so he fell into paganism
and that's the whole reason God isn't
God isn't a racist he's not saying don't
marry outside some people get it conf
and they think you're not supposed to
marry a different race or nationality
when in reality it was don't be
unequally yolked don't marry someone
that believes in other gods because will
corrupt you yeah I mean that's how yeah
that's how the
enemy uh defeated the Israelites they
said get the Pagan women to put on a
party and dance and we'll get him that
way exactly they got him yep without
firing a shot exactly so
that's the point is so they even know
Satanist
luciferians occultist they all know
about Solomon's Temple and how he got so
deep into the occult yeah that they want
to be just like him
right and so that's the connection there
anyway now let's see ashir is associated
with The Phoenician goddess estarte in
the Bronze Age the Canaanite Ashira
known as aeat the wife of L and the
mother of the Gods was a principal deity
entire so different regions are coming
up with different names but they're all
the
same however the specific name of
estarte is also found in the Bible such
as in judges 2 and 1st Samuel 7
therefore if there's a connection
between air and aarte they must be one
and the same y Divine name changes and
in cultural correlations are common in
many ancient mythologies that's true
similarly ashir is often interlaced with
various other deities of different names
and is believed to have a diverse icon
iconography her mythology is hard to
determine because in addition to
aarte she often took on attributes of
anat and Ishtar or Nana as well the
Babylonian goddess asatu appears to be a
version of Ashira and she was known for
her eroticism so there's the connection
with the poles and the fertility rights
and eroticism ayous
or um regions there we go um the
Babylonians learned of her through the
amorites who saw her as the consort of
the god amuru in Babylon she was thought
to be the daughter-in-law of Anu and was
known as the lady of the Steeps Steeps
are mountains oh okay hillsides Groves
right Bohemian grov exactly I think it's
interesting it does talk
about these poles and eroticism
that's the stripper poles and there's a
there's a billboard in a city close by
and you can see it right when you get
off the interstate and it's just a big
billboard with a a
silhouette of a you know how they always
do like the silhouette of a woman just
like the picture you showed the
silhouette of a woman on a pole and it
says Babylon it's a strip club named
Babylon with the girl in the pole like
it's literally so in her face why would
why would strip club pick that name they
know it's wrong you know they Babylon is
associated with sin just like you you
know go to Vegas and it's called Sin
City let's go to Sin City and we think
it's fun
um uh Broadway you know the Bible says
don't take the Broadway take the narrow
way right broad is a way that leads to
destruction and yet we we look at that
like Glitz and Glam I wish I was on
Broadway yeah Hollywood the the wood of
witches wands yeah us right in her face
mhm so excuse me it says her association
with mountains in Babylon may be a hint
of her Canaanite
Origins because she's the same one and
the same as
Ashira um even though she might be
called Anana in the fertility Cult of
Baal and Ashira there were two groups of
functionaries called
quim and
quat in Hebrew the two words literally
mean the the holy ones and many English
Bibles translate the word quim as male
cult prostitutes wow I cited it right
there from First Kings 15: 12 and the
word quat as female cult prostitutes in
Hosea
4:14 interesting yeah does I I've seen
whenever I'm looking up uh pagan gods to
see how they associate with like Comic
Book Heroes or whatever mhm they do have
different
names and sometimes they it's like it
it's this Roman God is the same Greek
god so the Greek and Roman they're like
interchangeable but they're different
Gods uh like Hermes is one of them I'm
trying to remember
but along the lines of they change names
today they're superheroes so you might
in the in the future in the far future
they'll look back and say in their
history books they'll say yep we
got um Hermes and later he was called
flash yeah we had Aqua or we had Neptune
later they called him Aquaman because
these names they do just change
depending on what culture you're in and
now we we have those same Gods today
different package different name true so
this is how
um I guess I'll just point out the
pictures of course we have the large
lady holding her breast that's
Anana but
um this was like I don't know just
femininity this was actually being
strong like all of these people and
being gender fluid I will point out and
I'm sorry to do this but the one that
has the swans down the picture of this
the lady with the swans um you mentioned
pan but we have beastiality that comes
into this as well there's a mythology of
a goddess associated with I think Anana
where she has two
geese and she ends up um having
relations with them wow well yeah that's
you know or swans I think most people
might not admit it or recognize it but
pansexual would
include because it what pansexual
literally means
is I don't care what you have I
mean like if if someone was attracted if
somebody went to a bar and they saw this
beautiful woman and they took her home
and was going to go to bed with them and
found out that they were actually a
transgender with with male parts they'd
be like I'm fine with that too it's just
like whatever goes you know there's no
rules I'm cool with anything and so why
wouldn't that include animals as well
pan seexual literally just me means mhm
the most debaucherous sexual lifestyle
you can have right and there's people
that are saying they are that yeah I
mean there's Demi Lovato says she's
pansexual it's becoming trendy to become
pansexual now yeah it's
crazy all right so here's where I know
this sounds terrible but we've only
gotten to the flood so far folks awesome
Genesis that was all of the biblical um
civilizations Before the Flood now we
come to Egypt wow um so the storm God
associated with many natural disasters
Seth in Egyptian while married to his
sister here we go again his
sister nephus is depicted as engaging in
sexual activities with other male
deities such as Horus described as
having impotent testicles he never had a
child this may not be a sign of great
tolerance in the culture
Seth was cast in a terrible terribly
negative light in many stories and while
his childbearing siblings Osirus and
Isis represent life he represents the
desert this may indicate a certain
negative sentiment about gay
identity really mhm the negative
MH so well because if you're gay you
can't reproduce Bear yeah you can't bear
children these cultures are all about
fertility exactly so strange again Satan
is clever because he's inciting this and
people don't even know what they're
getting into and then all of a sudden
it's like this was a fertility cult it
still is to this God worshiping them but
all of a sudden it's like you can't even
bear children from
that not that you should but I'm just
saying um ironic so Horus as it was
mentioned was his kind of lover many
tales about Seth focus on his Envy of
his nephew Horus so he is actually
having relations with his nephew gross
the child of Isis and Osiris which were
his
sisters in one tale documented well in
Richard par Parkinson's homosexual
desire and Middle Kingdom literature
Horus is either raped or seduced into a
sexual encounter Seth intends to
embarrass Horus by showing others Horus
was the receptive partner in the ACT but
Horus gets the upper hand because he
secretly captures Seth Seaman
then has his mother Isis feed it back to
Seth in his lettuce oh my god when the
seman is called forth by Seth an attempt
to humiliate Horus it comes from Seth
instead interestingly enough the Tale
shows that ancient Egyptian culture
didn't look down on homosexuality
something Horus engaged in himself okay
wow we have a lot of confusion here yes
yes but I think it's interesting because
they were talking about
humiliating someone else by showing that
they were on the receiving end and
they're raped that happens in these
secret societies and these Hollywood
Elites and all that yeah they have to go
through these initiation things they
call in in the college World they call
it hazing in the Freemason world it's
these initiations and stuff and they
have to go to these secret parties and
do unspeakable things and all of it is
captured on
camera
because you know that's why part of part
of the Illuminati
sorry part of the Illumina symbolism is
the the finger over the mouth the shush
the keeping the secret because if you
get out of line once you you know once
you've sold your soul for riches and
fame which Satan gives you that he can
give you that he's the God of this world
he offered it to Jesus I'll give you all
the kingdoms of the world if you bow
down to me if he can offer that to Jesus
he can offer it to any one of us and I
believe there's many people that took
that offer not realizing what they were
getting themselves into and how
disgusting all that world is and they
went out but now it's too late yeah now
there's blackmail on them and everything
and if they start to you know speak out
or try to escape then those things start
to leak out either either this is going
to come out and ruin your reputation or
going to get you
imprisoned uh you know I just look at
Michael Jackson and stuff that I don't
know I'm not saying he's completely
innocent I don't know I don't think so
but but when he started speaking out and
saying uh the the odor of Sony is the
devil and all this stuff he was really
like on stage saying stuff about these
higher ups that are in control of
everything and he was terrified he said
they're they're trying to kill me and
all this stuff and then he end ends up
dead MH um but what I'm saying is they
there was a big smear campaign against
his
reputation that went public all this
stuff was starting to come out and I
think it was that blackmail stuff and so
I just think it's interesting that this
goes way back to these ancient gods that
they were saying oh look who was on the
receiving end and all that very true W
all right so ironically the Egyptians
were rich I shouldn't say rich rich in
culture that included many rulers and
people that
were trans or lgbtq or whatever they had
an abundance yes so the next
one is
antinous this Resurrection figure so now
all a sudden we have like a Christ
figure holds ties to ancient Egyptian
Greek and Roman cultures anus was a real
historical figure F and the male
companion of the Roman Emperor hadrien
the pair would take Journeys around the
Mediterranean and on one trip anius
drowned in the Nile on the same day that
the Egyptians commemorated the watery
death of
Osiris deeply affected by the death of
his lover hadrien encouraged the
deification of Antonius and Colts sprung
up around the Mediterranean honoring him
in some tellings antinas Rose from the
Nile after his death and was then
revered as a for of Osiris reborn indeed
the God and the Roman cult that followed
him still have devotees today
wow and what is this God antinas anus
still have devotees today
mhm um gay
guy a tomb in the creation story for the
Egyptian gods the first deity the first
deity that's interesting they're saying
that so he's like the very first on top
great God aumb was both male and
female according to Studies by
researcher Mark Burman the ancestor to
all self-produced
to the ancestor to all self-produced two
Offspring Shu and tefnut through either
a sneeze or his own seamen and it wasn't
for a few Generations that the arc
typical male and female gods of Isis and
Osiris were then born
W so he could produce life on his own he
was asexual okay yeah in other words
yeah yeah well
mhm okay so then we have
nephus while there are fewer tales in
Egyptian history and mythology about
female than male homosexuality many
consider the goddess nephus to be a
lesbian the sister and constant
companion of Isis she married her
brother Seth but bore him no children
Scholars have debated whether the
stories of nephus who did Bear one son
by
Osiris show that the culture held
lesbians in Greater esteem than gay men
because they could still be fertile
despite their sexual
orientation fertile but can't reproduce
if they're only engaging in the lesbian
lifestyle true but Osiris was a female
as well so nephus and Osiris you
know that's what I'm saying though if
you got what you mean two fertile
lesbians are not going to reproduce
right and then Isis Isis was among the
few goddesses woried both by the
Egyptians and their Mediterranean
Neighbors in Greece the mother goddess
and the protector of children she also
cared for societies downtrodden which
may be why gay priests in ancient Egypt
worshiped the
deity in one tale documented at
ISO IOP pois
Isis appeared in a dream accompanied by
an Egyptian retinue to calm the pregnant
Tusa who feared she would deliver a girl
against her husband's wish husband's
wishes Isis told the mother to carry the
child if who was born a girl but raised
as a boy later in life if called on Isis
to change his gender to
male in an ancient gender affirmation
granted by Divine means in the story W
so what I think is
interesting is that what's her name
Rihanna has that tattoo Isis tattoo yeah
on her chest yeah these these people
these Elites they are all into this
stuff
and it said gay priests M and we were
just talking about how the pope of the
Catholic Church of the papacy he wears
that Deon hat these are is Egyptian
Babylonian mhm worship mhm and they are
these gay priests like this stuff has
been exposed that theyve they were
involved in abusing children mainly men
with
boys and so it's the same thing it's
repackaged and and even guised in
Christianity people think that the
Catholic church is Christian when it's
literally no Babylon had to get a new
disguise that wasn't ostracized and it
became the Catholic church right right
crazy so then we have raw or
rot who is um Sun God but while the sun
god raw in most mythological accounts
was regarded as the father to the major
Gods sir Ernest Alfred Wallace budge
wrote of a clear indications of double
gender nature in the deity as early as
the fifth Dynasty budge wrote of raw's
female
counterpart rot who is considered the
mother of the
Gods so then all of a sudden we have
someone who's just
like I'm
both oh yeah I mean that's the whole
gender fluid thing mhm
okay so
next man I'm not going to even say those
names the clearest evidence that
bisexuality was acceptable in ancient
Egypt may be the tomb of these two men
LA to rest in the ne necropolis of
saara of
saara hieroglyphics indicate that the
men were married with children but also
show them an intimate embrace the two
men apparently worked as overseas to
manicurists overseers I'm sorry to
manicurist in the Palace of King
Noir there is some scholarly debate as
to whether the men were brothers but
virtually all depictions of the pair
show a commitment that looks far from
fraternal yeah right I mean I wouldn't
get that close to my brother mouth to
mouth like that mhm yeah that's not a
greet with a holy kiss no and then
there's hat sheps the first documented
transgender figure in history um that
may have that was an Egyptian
pharaoh
um this person deer Ramsey M mckin of
something publishing says that unlike
other female Egyptian rulers hat chepet
was always depicted in Ancient Art
wearing men's clothing and she fre
frequently was drawn with a male body
and a strap on
beard her descendant tetos III would
later try to eradicate nearly all
historic reference to her oh so I've
definitely seen that head with that
square beard on it that's a strapon
beard yes okay makes sense
and I've heard that some people say she
had to or or people wouldn't respect her
as a ruler you had to look like a male
like men Could Only Rule
but why would you consent to that why
would you already just give into that
and be like sure I'll be both I'll be
I'll be a different gender yeah if you
want girl power then be a girl not I
have to disguise myself as a man then
you're not really in power at all right
you're actually submitting to the whole
misogynistic mhm thing
okay so then we have these two men as
well the Egyptian king himself who many
scholars believe Rose to become Pharaoh
Pepe
II would make conspicuous midnight
visits to his favorite General sasset
according to Tales during the era of the
Middle
Kingdom according to German Scholars
Gunter Burkhart and K fisen
some ancient texts state that
this Pharaoh would do to the military
leader what his majesty desired
nefari
yes a phrase they interpret as clear
innuendo of sexual
Congress sexual
Affairs what his majesty desired that
was the phrase
yes then there's happy the god of the
Nile she he sorry he she he's depicted
in hieroglyphics as an intersex person
there you go yeah with a ceremonial
ceremonial false beard and breasts while
generally referred to as a male the god
also was considered a symbol of
fertility according to Richard
Parkinson's the deity was betrayed to
suggest both male and female
reproductive power a topic that has
incited debate among Scholars so that's
the picture there you can see the
breasts are insinuated the the belly is
there for fertility and bearing children
that's what I was going to say it looks
like it has a pregnant stomach yeah but
it's a
male which we see today man I see more
and more like it looks like a guy with a
beard with a pregnant belly giving birth
yeah so crazy and then there's another
water god named waj Weir um for
fertility a deity depicted at a pyramid
site in Abu seir sometimes referred to
as the pregnant God again which held the
same type of station as River gods in
Greek mythology representing the
Mediterranean Sea in some accounts or
rivers and lagoons of the north Nile
Delta and others in association with
water given the wavy lines in the skin
which seems the greatest distinguishing
feature separating him from happy he
carries an offering loaf on a mat with
an ank symbol suspended from his arm
with his androgynous form large breasts
in a belly represent
pregnancy waj Weir is associated with
fertility and prosperity he continued to
be referred to throughout ancient Egypt
Egyptian history especially through
protective amulets and tomb inscriptions
so here we have like the offering of a
red
item yeah very interesting interesting y
all right so in a
religious ceremony ceremony yeah mhm
it's a counter of the Last Supper you
know Jesus did break bread with his
disciples before he was crucified and he
said do this in remembrance of me but of
course Satan's going to counterfeit all
these things um I know that the Bible
talks about cakes were offered up to the
Queen of Heaven yeah and the Catholic
Church likes to call Mary the Queen of
Heaven which she's not but when you look
up the Queen of Heaven who is the Queen
of Heaven in the Bible it's a false god
there's nothing good said about the
queen of heaven in the Bible um and and
this
Babylonian sect uh that disguises itself
as a Christian Catholic church or
whatever right they're still performing
these ceremonies of the cakes to the
Queen of Heaven
yes not to mention the idol worship that
you can see around there there's always
the food y the cakes yeah the
fruit so all
right um then we get to the Roman gods
Venus there was in Cyprus a statue of a
bearded Venus who is considered to be of
both sexes and to whom sacrifice was
offered by men dressed as women and
women dressed as men hm the noisy
procession of galle is very
top um or unic Priests of cbel the
mother of the Gods paraded the towns and
Villages of Syria Asia Minor and other
parts attired as women and soliciting
the populace to Unholy rights wow so
they made the connection between Venus
and cbel there and these erotic Unholy
rituals and them dressing no matter if
you're women you dress like a man if
you're a man you dress like a woman yeah
there's also Aphrodite in the Babylonian
culture Aphrodite is the goddess of
prostitution there's another Bell that
should go off yeah we already mentioned
prostitution elsewhere but she had both
male and female
prostitutes she also had inir which were
hermaphrodite shamans who wore women's
clothes and received the gift of
divination from the goddess this came
about also with a tale of a Aphrodite
and the God Hermes having a child named
hermaphroditism half female person that
was interesting in ancient Greece
afrodite was the goddess of fertility
love and joy this is important for us to
understand that on her behalf Brides
would prostitute themselves to bring
luck to their
marriage that's not lucky marriage wow
but listen they say why it's supposed to
be lucky the most shameful of the
Customs among the Babylonians is this it
is necessary for each Local woman to sit
in the sanctuary of Aphrodite just once
in their life to mingle with a foreign
man for
money a tro set up with money earned
with sacred prostitution would be even
more blessed than a common one so your
diary doesn't matter your prostitution
money does Yeah by providing love and
pleasure in the name of the Goddess
these Brides would attract happiness and
luck to
themselves now in the priestess's case
sex would be one of the many forms of
worship to Aphrodite Venus or milita
Molita depending on the place and the
name of the deity it changes but their
characteristics are basically the
same um I notice you know it talks about
I know the the scientific term medical
term um a hermaphrodite someone that's
born with both male and female genitalia
it's it's a mutation it's not you know
some people might try to use that as see
some people are born both and non-binary
and fluid and all this stuff no it's a
mutation some people are born with a you
know and siese Twins or I don't know if
that's a politically correct term but
conjoin
twins it's just a mutation that happens
and a mutation quite honestly in the
scientific world is a defect yeah it's
something that happened in your genes
where they didn't cross correct right
correctly and then spread to create a
normal cell yeah what I'm getting at is
that they call that a hermaphrodite
right the terminology used in the
medical world is based off of this God
exactly ancient god yeah it's crazy that
is all right more on um Aphrodite the
English name anire is derived from the
ancient Greek name recorded by
herodes Herod
Herodotus of
halaris oh yeah pardon my
pronunciation as anars itself derived
from the cian term aneria meaning
unmanly huh
H the aneria used cannabis in their
rituals including both those of a
communal and those of a ferary or
psychop ppic nature thus being among the
earliest spiritual practitioners to have
used cannabis to achieve altered state
States Of Consciousness implying that an
ancient connection existed between
gender non-conforming spiritual
practitioners and the use of
mind-altering
substances after the burial burial of
this of the deceased they ritually
cleanse themselves with a vapor of
cannabis which is a tested archaeologic
Ally in Saka tombs from Siberia where
which contained tripods bers pelts Anda
charcoal containing remnants sorry
remains of cannabis leaves and
fruits Aphrodite was the goddess the
Greek goddess of love and beauty she was
the most beautiful of the goddesses but
was married to the ugliest of the Gods
the limp
Smithy heest heest I would say say
that's pan basically but I don't know if
that's the same well there's a picture
it looks like pan right that is her but
Aphrodite had many affairs with men both
human and divine resulting in many
children including Aeros which actually
becomes Cupid C
anos I don't know how to say that himnos
and
Aus Alia which is
Splender myth all of these other other
children um and so she actually birthed
more and more Gods like this is actually
how you start understanding that
happened in their mythology it's strange
it's like just a bunch of orgies and
cheating on each other Cupid that's
associated with Valentine's Day and it's
just we're
showing from history that every holiday
that people keep these days is rooted in
paganism yes yes so in cbel which is a
frigi and god
goddess similarly they had
gal or galle unic priests which served
the goddess cbel she's also called the
mother of the Gods as the Greeks saw her
with roots in Eastern Turkey going back
to at least 6,000 BCE cbel was seen as
syncretic with other ancient early
mothers Ria demer
Gaia ader
gadus Mother Earth the Syrian goddess so
they're actually telling us that Mother
Earth was always a part of this for one
and that's how the syrians actually
titled
her who also had queer priesthoods all
of these people had queer priesthoods
yeah cbel worshiped H Sor sorry cybel
worship became the official religion of
the Roman Empire around 200 bcee when
she was adopted as its Magnum Mater or
great
mother the Romans enlisted her support
on the ad of an Oracle in their campaign
to dominate the the Mediterranean World
interesting a black meteorite represents
her and was brought from antolia to Rome
and a magnificent Temple constructed for
the goddess in the city her Camp
flamboyant long-haired loud and queer
gal priests and her female priestesses
called the Melissa or the bees wow which
made me think of Beyonce and her bees
yep queen bee queen bee
it came they all came with her but the
galet so shocked the Roman locals that
they were forced to live outside the
cities they formed traveling bands
bringing Lively intoxicated goddess
worship to the people and some followed
the Roman soldiers wherever they went
bringing the goddess often wild sexual
and ecstatic worship as far as Britain
and
Spain during the first century of cel's
time in Rome Roman citizens were not
allowed to undergo the initiatory act of
ritual castration I don't know why but
this was inspired by a story of Addis
lover of cbel so here we we come by the
the story of why castration for this
particular
goddess so her lover this male Addis
castrated himself while in a sexual
frenzy to avoid marrying a human
woman the gala priests mourned for Addis
and self- castrated themselves to be
better servants to the goddess in 101
BCE the law was changed so that certain
citizens could become
gal and then it was removed from the
remaining removed the remaining
restrictions this tolerance only lasted
for a short time but
tolerance y there you go
tolerance and it was soon removed for
good as Christianity quote unquote
Christianity there you go Consolidated
its power in the
Empire um before you move on I noticed
that talk about a black rock yes a black
meteorite
represents this God right C this goddess
and so I looked up um just to make sure
I had my facts right I said what is
inside the mecca Cube which for anybody
that doesn't know Mecca is where all
the uh Muslims go however often they go
and there's a giant black Cube they all
walk circles around it I asked Google
what is inside of that Cube and it says
a black stone also known as alhar Al
Awad this stone is located in the
cabba's eastern Corner Muslims rever the
stone which is believed to have been
given
to I don't know this word Abraham I
guess Abraham it's spelled with a I
here by the angel Gabriel so there's a
stone a black stone that was given to
humanity by an Angel yeah the black
stone was originally a single piece of
rock but is now made up of several
pieces that have been cemented together
and surrounded by a silver
frame um let's
see it says basically they call it a
meteor right M so that's what this is it
is a a symbol it's the symbol of syb Bel
yes but and it came from Heaven it fell
from heaven think bigger than that so
you have the cube of Mecca for the
Islamic
faith in the Jewish faith they I don't
know what it's called but the Black Cube
on their for supposedly with the Torah
that they wear on their foreheads right
but when it really boils down to
everything it's cybel and her meteorite
or the Black Cube of Saturn wow yeah
that's true which I'm not going to get
into you can watch the bail thing it
gives you basically what that is right
um yeah it's like you you mentioned the
Cube part in that but now we're getting
to this Black Rock part which represents
cbell and you got these companies like
black rock that own everything right
it's wow crazy yes okay so that was just
a little side thing but side Bell is
depicted as collie that's actually one
of her other names in India the um she
has lots of breasts sometimes and um she
always has Lions around her and she was
known for as the goddess of thresholds
transitions literal transitions people
this is gender transition and Street
Raves okay yeah so more on her because
it's necessary she was
named Aster goddess or cbel Artemis in
Ephesus so here we're actually seeing as
her name changes I should really include
the top part I'm sorry in various forms
in Syria and Asia Minor as well as in
Rome she was known as the great
mother and she was uh was known under
the name of
asterus or cbel Artemis in Ephesus
during Paul's story for Paul's day in
Syria known as Ria the effeminized
priests init imitated the Deeds of Addis
in a trans-like
ecstasy oh sorry trans like ecstasies
including the rights of cbel or
Ria actually included baptism in the
blood of a slaughtered bull or Ram that
occurred in the toru
bolum at the end of the ceremony powers
of the bull within its genitals were
offered to the mother of the Gods again
a symbol male
emasculation of men under the occultt
power of the Goddess Austine in his city
of God vividly describes the games
honored in honor of tanit the celestial
virgin and mother of the gods were
obscene actors roleplay disgusting acts
in the presence of an immense throng of
Spectators and listeners of both sexes
he also describes the public display of
homosexual priests so this is very
interesting because this is her priest
that's up top there in in the black
background and has the Fran hat on
doesn't have much else on but um these
are the bull fights that we would think
of right in the you know the Pope that
the pope has
the pope has bull fights yeah oh I
didn't know that but I know I know it
happens in Spain and there he attends
them yeah um where did I see when it
talks about the great mother when you
look that term up in the Bible you're
going to see like the great mother of
harlots I just you know so much of this
stuff has red flags when you actually
know the Bible and that's why it's so
important to study the Bible because
Satan's deceptions are so subtle
they look so close to the truth that
we're going to fall for them if we
don't if you don't study the truth
you're going to fall for the counterfeit
right um I was noticing something about
this it said the celestial virgin yes
and I know that the Catholic Church
calls Mary like a Perpetual virgin yes
she wasn't yes she she was married to
Joseph and Jesus had Brothers all this
is in the Bible she's not a virgin
throughout you've been noticing the
Virgin the mother of the Gods you know
what I mean you've been noticing all the
Queen of Heaven all these these titles
they give Mary when it's not Mary at all
right yeah it's not a CBO right so was
that all you wanted to say yeah okay
going on the second uh par paragraph
there it says the cult of cbel also
known as Magnum which is the great
mother would be part of Rome's fabric
until its christianization when she
became known as mother Mary or the
Virgin Mary there yeah there you go her
statue was paraded through the streets
annual leak accompanied by long-haired
priests armed with musical instruments
and feling themselves which means
whipping themselves with whips made of
knuckle bones these priests were called
The Galley we just spoke about that the
galley differenti them differentiated
themselves from Roman Civic religion
through their clothing and behavior
after entering the cult and castrating
themselves The Galley wore the clothing
and jewelry of a Roman woman they may
have received secondhand clothes and are
other goods from women in exchange for
fortune telling so they mentioned
fortune telling
divination um Clairvoyance all these
things so far yeah which does seem to be
the the dots the connecting the dots
that comes with the spiritual power of
this also in Corey bon in mythology were
seven rustic demigods or demons demons
appointed by Zeus to guard the infant
dionis and his nurse the nymph misus or
macis on the island of Y yuboa okay so
that's another that's a picture of Cory
bontes on the
bottom however those in service to cbel
that were Cory bontes were dancers
shrieking wildly as they danced so we
should be thinking about that and we're
going to connect the dots
there in a
minute I want to I don't want to break
the
um the flow the flow of things here but
there is somebody in the comments
section here this is live so we're
getting comments coming in this actually
a friend of ours Aaron and he said um
did you see that Cat Williams was on Joe
Rogan talking about what exactly did he
say uh it says Mikey did you hear what
Cat Williams said about the transgender
God worshiped in Hollywood
and he sent me a link it's a five minute
clip it says Cat Williams on Joe Rogan
talking about baffet and I just think
it's interesting
that things are starting to come out
people thought you know God woke me up
to this stuff in 2012 New World Order
Illuminati all this type of stuff and I
was just like I'm going to wake the
sleeping giant I just put it all out
there and people start stopped friending
me you know unfriending me and I thought
I was crazy mhm but now people on the
inside are starting to speak out you
know now that everybody has like podcast
there's lots of different ways to get
your voice out there even as a celebrity
you don't really have a voice because
your platform is controlled right it's
it's controlled by Universal Sony
whatever but now with these free
platforms like YouTube and podcast and
all this stuff the truth is getting out
there and so I did want to plug that if
anybody wants to look into that after
the show or whatever check out Cat
Williams uh talking about the baffet on
Joe Rogan I'm going to watch it too
thanks a okay good
connection so this was on medium written
by the gay priest the goddess today they
actually call themselves gay priestesses
of the
goddess and they say the effeminacy of
priests was so deeply embedded in the
collective Consciousness I wanted proof
from them yeah that's what I'm getting
at here that Christianity insisted its
priests be celibate and continue to wear
frocks for the public would not readily
accept married priests quote unquote
Christian right this is the Catholic
Church the mother of the Gods also
admits eminates and the goddess would
not judge so if by Nature unmanliness
were a trivial thing wrote Greek
philosopher sexus empiricus in the 2
Century castration was common among the
goddess priesthoods and was popular too
among the early Christians
so again Christians we really have to
think about that word whenever it's used
in the history books today it just means
Roman Catholicism right I don't know why
but they they got that term given to
them yeah and Christians today real
Protestant churches were never the
church right we are never the church
yeah if if you look up what's the
world's largest Christian denomination
it's going to say the Catholic church
it's amazing that Satan has corrupted
the majority of Christianity because if
you're not Catholic which is the
majority of the quote unquote Christian
world and it's completely Babylonian
paganism um then you're a part of some
other denomination that is not believing
what the Bible actually teaches such
as you don't have to obey the
Commandments of God or something like
that you know I've I was raised in these
churches that believe look I said that
little prayer I'm good to go once save
always save I said the magic prayer and
I can live my life the way I want to and
I get to go to heaven and nothing can
prevent me from going that's a satanic
lie there is no such thing as a once
saved always saved there's a a
relationship and as long as you keep
that relationship then you're good I
mean that's what Christ wants a
relationship with us but like the
prodical son if you choose to walk away
God allows you that freedom it breaks
his heart but he's not going to force
anyone into heaven he's not gonna Force
anyone to be in love with him because
love cannot be forced and so as long as
you're in love with Christ and you keep
that relationship strong you pick up
your cross daily you uh endure until the
end all these things are in the Bible
what are you enduring if it's just you
say a magic prayer and that's it what
are you what cross are you picking up
daily what transformation renewing of
your mind all these things that the
Bible says the fruit you will know them
by their fruits not because you Proclaim
to be a Christian have a wear a cross
and have
Bible in your and go to church that
doesn't make you a Christian it's the
fruit you know them by the fruits and
what are the fruits it's not going to be
you look just like the world it's not
going to be you're you're the same
person you were 10 years ago as you are
now yeah um so I just say all that to
say that it's amazing we live in a time
when the majority of Christianity isn't
even
Christian that's the deception right
there yeah very true so I just wanted to
make that distinction but
um and it was in Catholicism just as it
says castration was common among the
goddess priesthoods and was a popular
too among the early Christians
Catholics homosexually had homosexuality
had been part of religious life for so
long that some Gnostic Christians
favored it over procreative sex
historian Randy Connor quotes fourth
Century
cypriot uh Bishop if EP Venice on one of
these Gnostic
sect those among them who are called
Levites do not have intercourse with
women but with each other oh my goodness
and it is these which are actually
distinguished and honored among them so
here we have the idea INF flipped on its
head that who quoted this some historian
okay yes of these of the Goddess here I
I want to see where he got this Source
because I don't believe it yeah and so
led by those who embodied female the
unic was termed was a term sorry used in
a very broad sense to refer to men who
did not procreate and unic were often
looked upon as a third gender Jesus
refers they say Jesus refers to the
gospel of Matthew to Unix
saying there are Unix who have been so
from birth and there are Unix who have
been made Unix by others there are Unix
who have made themselves Unix for the
sake of the Kingdom of Heaven let anyone
accept this who can
so they're actually saying it's an
honored position if you do so yeah and
you're doing it for God yes wow ballis
sades a gnostic Christian in Alexandria
living around 125 to 150 CE argued Jesus
was here referred to three type
referring sorry to three types of male
celibates those with their natural
revulsion to women those who practice
aestheticism atic I think I said that
right
out of a desire for Glory from their
peers and those who remain unmarried to
better do the work of the
Kingdom note the first type here
exclusively same seex oriented people
have always existed they did not
suddenly find a sense of identity and
community in the 19th century as many
think today so this is a gay group
saying this well I mean the Bible in the
Old Testament condemns homosexual
homosexuality the book of Genesis mhm
talks about Sodom and Gomorrah and what
was going on there so I mean for anybody
that think this is something new hip and
trendy is just ignorant right
so let's continue in Greek we have bakus
the god bakus or also known as
dionis and this is important because we
do have certain elements coming in here
he's the god Greek god of wine he in
this uh religion also invaded India long
before Alexander the Great was born
therefore you can find the worship of
dionis in India through wrs and reliefs
dionis is an ancient Greek god and also
part of the Roman Pantheon he was known
as Bist to the Romans and was connected
with the Italian God of fertility and
wine Liber Potter is also a named for
him interestingly he is also associated
with India and is often mentioned in
references of classical Antiquity
according to myth dianis the wine God
arrived in India and conquered the lands
founded cities and established laws in
order to elicit Altered States of mind
and spiritual consciousness which
appears to be what the worship of dianis
is centered around one would participate
in orgies beastiality sensual pleasure
singing dancing in all obscenities
beginning with the drinking of copious
amounts of wine dressing like a half
human half animal here we have FES yes
while doing these things was a part of
the custom for ritual rights uh
particular rights wearing masks to hide
identity and be non-conformist to a
given identity was also used this is so
crazy that everything that we think is
like new hip trendy weird you know cool
is it's just literally Satan has inched
his way back into our culture
today something that we look used to
look at and say man I would never do any
of that Beast Al this is gross all this
stuff that just in the '90s you know
growing up mhm we would have thought all
this was crazy disgusting who would ever
do that and in a few short Generations
you know 10 years here 10 years there
we're in a culture where people go to
hotels they rent whole parts of the
hotel dress up as animals drink copious
amounts of wine the whole ritual that
was described and engaging I don't know
who it is could be my sister could be my
brother I don't know is whatever
anything goes we're living it today yeah
it's insane so I looked this up because
I don't know why I got I got uh
interested in it so that picture from
Kora is actually someone saying how do I
worship dianis how do I Channel him they
said of course you can do so by
drinking wow that should be the easiest
way to invoke him that should be an eye
opener right there for anybody that's
still trying to hold on to drinking as a
Christian yes but they also say you can
practice forms of excitatory
Trance by doing so there's ecstatic
Dance I'm just going to read them
quickly that's the Raves y ecstasy and
dance then there's masturbation they say
which works
wonders then you can chant or sing
there's swinging or oscillating which
works masks are a big part of dianis so
putting on a mask and using your
imagination to place yourself in a
different context now think of that that
was the whole that's going to come back
I guess around to what we're going to
speak of a little bit later okay um and
meditation
so yeah meditation yeah interesting and
and everybody's doing that and they
don't even think it's a religious
act okay so with this being
said we're just going to highlight a few
things here and mainly what we're going
to see is that Greek Theater tragedies
and comedies comes into this while
you're all doing certain things and
unfortunately um engaging in tons of
drinking and sexual orgies and things
and no rules yeah there's a lot I'm just
GNA be honest there's a lot of raping
going on oh yeah yeah and furries and
all this things that are not right and
animal bestiality and all this stuff
right
but then it's all of a sudden become a
blood ritual there's a blood ritual with
this
aome well I guess that's where we have
to read more about this real quick
here um let's look at B andalia Balia by
the way is what we what became known as
Christmas oh wow so known to the Romans
as Balia these rights were originally
held in secret and only attended by
women over time they became co-ed and
interesting ly popular increasingly
popular the Bania were notorious for
their intensity and abandon participants
engaged in singing dancing and the
consumption of kop mounts of of wine
which facilitated an altered state of
consciousness then you have the Mantic
Mantic rights and the followers of
dionis particularly the manads engaged
in Wild forestbound rituals these female
devotees were portrayed as being in a
state of ecstatic Frenzy driven by
intoxication and divine possession they
danced shouted and were believed to
possess Supernatural strength often
depicted as tearing
animals apart with their bare
hands and sometimes humans a ritual act
called
Spar sparagmos followed by omophagia the
eating of the raw flesh I'm just going
to say people cannibalism yes but it
happens today this is part of the
rituals today as well the spirit cooking
and all this that the celebrities are
doing yes so I guess I can't get away
with just summarizing some of this I
have to read what's going on here the
mysteries of
dianis this was shrouded in rituals and
secrecy initiates would undergo symbolic
experiences of death and rebirth
paralleling the death and rebirth themes
of Dion isis's own myths these rights
promised personal purification and
renewal as well as a closer communion
with the divine
then you have processions and symbolic
implements which is dionan processions
which are offered featured phallic
symbols symbolizing fertility and were
accompanied by music from instruments
like the Tyrus a staff topped with a
pine cone oh there it is drums and
flutes the celebrants wore Ivy wreaths
there you go the ivy wreath and human
I'm sorry animal skins representing the
God's association with nature and the
Wild and sang about all kinds of obscene
things I mean that's every rap song
every you know anything you hear in the
club you're dancing to is full of
obscene things yeah literally yeah then
you have the satire plays which means
exactly what it it says there were
distinctive form of tragic comedy tragic
comedy featuring choruses of satire
mythical followers of dionis part man
and part beast and were an integral part
of the dionan festivals they combined
humor with horror and allowed for an
exploration of themes not typically
covered in the more formal tragedies
these rights not only served religious
purposes but also facilitated social
cohesion and catharsis among
participants so it's like yeah we're all
Brotherhood providing a space where
ordinary rules did not apply and
allowing individuals to step outside
their everyday
identities so we do we see a lot of this
happening today and I'm sorry if you
don't know that this is happening today
with our celebrities and with their
rituals like you're saying Hollywood
they do all this yeah they have all
these parties and yeah celebrities are
starting to say it now they're saying I
went to these parties I mean it's coming
out like uh P Diddy you know they're
saying I I was saw things happen at
those parties that were unspeakable
things MH and they're not just like
innocent little gatherings they're doing
vile things and these are the people
that we look up to we idolize them they
are literally the
new Greek and Roman gods that walk among
us there you go we think we live in such
a different world we don't it's the same
world it's just different we we look at
them like they're just some barbaric or
whatever they're just like us yeah
people you can't look at a certain time
period and say man those people really
dumb no we're doing the same
thing well which tells me we as God's
people have always struggled with the
same thing we keep following yeah
falling into the same sins we need to
get our act together yeah we need to
stop giving Satan that power yeah
because he basically we he deceives a
generation they wake up to that and he
deceives them a new way and but I
think I don't know yeah it's like now
it's on such a scale that it's not even
hidden where you watch the Grammy Awards
and it's all everything's red and
they're half naked on stage you can't
tell if they're male or female they're
wearing devil horns there's a big
pentagram on the stage everything's just
like so in your face and yet people are
still like ah it's just art just
entertainment whatever yeah no it's it
is symbolizing exactly the ancient
symbols it came from rituals and symbols
it came from yeah it's just getting more
and more open and people yeah or have
become desensitized to where they don't
even realize that this is real right
okay so sorry about those gross details
but that is where it came from that's
where it all got included this is from
the blbi the I guess the free online
Bible courses a Ministry of blue b
letter bible okay
and they
say um this is from the Pagan Spirit
Gathering we feel there is a power in
our sexuality so now we're applying it
to today what do pagans what do lgbtq
people say about themselves okay there's
a power in our sexuality a queer energy
that most cultures consider magical it
is practically a requirement for certain
kinds of medicine and Magic W Another
Gay Pagan confirms that the spiritual
Dynamic confirms the spiritual dynamic
damic it is simply easier to blend with
a natur a nature Spirit or a spirit of a
plant a plant or an animal if you are
not concerned with a gender specific
role the spiritual element is documented
through the history of pagan cultures in
which the shaman was often a homosexual
they're just distilling it down all the
things I've been showing you that's what
it is this is a like a
higher ritual ma magician magician
sorcerer sorcerer yep or doctor y um the
connection between androgyny and
homosexuality and Pagan religion has
existed all over the world in throughout
time here's a few modern examples in the
19th century BC mes Mesopotamia
androgynous Priests of Ishtar engaged in
trans like ecstasies and contact with
spirits of the underworld we already
knew that we covered that then we have
the Canaanite religions we were covered
as well and not cbel and Ria in the
Roman Empire androgynous priests
castrated the M themselves publicly as
an act of Devotion to the great mother
we knew that too oh that is some
devotion in Hinduism anyone who unifies
the sexes in sexual practice has reached
the highest
self-identity in the medieval West
Alchemists who transformed heterosexual
energy into androgyny produced spiritual
gold there we have the gold again gold
we start at the beginning with gold we
are going to talk about gold because
it's what they're looking for yeah
and it says a tremendously deepened
sense of the Oneness of all Beyond
gender differences what they call gold
right there the Pagan spiritualist Jacob
boham which is a Freemason source and a
cult Source believed the ideal human
state was androgyny in ancient Aztec and
Incan religions homosexual and bisexual
priests were common in American Indian
religious practices homosexual
transvesite males are their Shaman wow
in Latin America and the Caribbean
islands homosexuals were magicians with
Supernatural Powers frequently gay
Temple prostitutes were a means of
sanctification in in Jewish cabalism
they celebrate the idea of the first
Cosmic
androgyny and its modern form is
committed to Global spiritual
Oneness coexist mhm this is what Satan's
bringing about the one world religion he
has to get everyone to accept this stuff
yeah he has to get everyone this is
mindblowing I don't want to interrupt
you where are you at I'm here I I'm
right at Pim let me finish that part
real quick Pim which is one of the
Hebrew festivals that they
keep it's the Feast of lots I have it
right there allows for co uh
crossdressing okay and this is a Jewish
thing yeah yeah the Feast of lotes
anyway yeah and they allow crossdressing
yeah
when it's literally in the Bible don't
dress like the opposite
sex yeah yeah yeah okay so also other
examples I'm really going to fly through
this quickly medieval um Alchemist also
participated in go this goddess worship
South American Incans we already covered
that Eskimos in the Arctic African
Bushmen Aborigines in all of these the
sexual religious combo appears time and
time again in these places we see the
onest Pagan
ideology which says man in such diverse
parts of the world are committed to and
involved in the same religious practices
shamanistic homosexuality is an organic
expression of onest
spirituality W you can go now what I'm
what I'm seeing what you're bringing out
is for one Satan does have an agenda to
bring all of humanity into a one world
religion one world one world just like
Babylon the Tower of
Babel but he has to get people to accept
his way the most debaucherous things and
we're literally at a time where I was in
what I was in Wyoming I was just I just
got back a couple days ago from Wyoming
where Mount Rushmore is it's
like everywhere you go is American flags
this is all like Republican right like
this is a small town you know lots of
land but not a lot of people 33,000
people in the whole uh State lots of
land but they are all you know wearing
Trump hats and stuff and when we went to
downtown I saw lots of churches downtown
and I saw one with a giant pride flag
hanging on the building on the outside
of the building of a Christian Church
is why why would you fly flag of all the
things you're not flying the American
flag I don't even agree with that I
don't agree with hanging any flag on a
church but of all things that you would
choose to we're going to fly a flag on
the church building not your country not
the the cross not Jesus on a banner but
the homosexual gay pride flag which I
I've tried to say this on every every
time this topic comes up I don't believe
that that flag is just a gay flag right
it's not it's it's the flag of Lucifer
it's the flag of Satan himself you can
look up Lucifer jacket look up Lucifer
jacket and you'll see people wearing
this leather jacket with the word
Lucifer and every letter is a different
color of the rainbow only six right l u
c i f e r okay every color of the
rainbow all seven his flag is the flag
of Pride Satan fell because of PR Pride
it's not a gay flag it's a pride flag
and they keep adding to it it's not just
homosexuals now we're going to add
transgender now we're going to add um
BLM like there's the the black stripe
there's the brown stripe oh you're
you're a brown skinn minority we want to
put you on the flag we want to get
everybody to embrace this flag yeah
now the church is flying it right so um
to kind of go through this some more it
says on on the far right the lie about
sexuality this is a credible Source from
um a college Siberian Shaman known as
chikuchi in Central
Asia engage in ecstatic rituals and
dresses androgynus we have all these in
Borneo I'm just going to skip through
this in the Amazon you have shamans that
do this Celtic priests Indian hijas
which are men dressing as women and
doing these um div divination and
such we have the
navajos they have all of it there I'm
just I'm not going to read the rest um
but it's basically in every culture
that's really what I'm getting at and
they're getting at so this is a picture
up top of these Indian hijas these
actual men who do this wow um that's a
picture of below that on the far left is
uh Navajo Shaman who looks
like androgynous and then they
contrasted that with a picture of an
actual LGBT person today on the right
and you can't really tell what's going
on but it looks very
similar they say later in the second and
third centuries of the Christian Church
the gnostics were credited by their
adversaries with mystery celebrations
involving carnal knowledge that's what
we're getting at this carnal knowledge
the charge is a credible is credible
because Christian gnosticism was the
attempt to christianize Pagan
spirituality even to the point of
adopting some form of
androgyny hippol
litis or hippius reports that one
particular agnostic sect the nines or
Asen who worshiped the serpent Nas in
Hebrew of Genesis attended the secret
ceremonies of the Mysteries of the great
mother in order to understand the
universal mystery
Universal mystery we should have some
other Bells going off again we have
ecumenicism the Catholic Church which
means The Universal Church the universal
mystery like modern syncretist so
syncretist take all religions they
combine all of them we all they're all
equal they're all amazing they all lead
to God and a power the force of a
greater being out there and everything
and they say they are encouraged to
cross over into other religions the
gnostics believed religious truth was
one to be found everywhere and so they
crossed over into Pagan spirituality as
a matter of religious principle the most
explicit testimony is from irius who
says they prepare a bridal chamber and
celebrate Mysteries a homosexual
encounter is perhaps insinuated in the
secret Gospel of Mark they say at the
very least the Gospel of Thomas appears
to be an invitation to spiritual
androgyny all this would justify the
Judgment of
burer that certain Gnostic sects seem to
have practiced mystery initiations
imitating or rather outdoing the pagans
this is also where tantric yoga comes
from Wow Shakti who sleeps in the shape
of a serpent or Kundalini at the base of
his body is woken by certain yogic
techniques she moves by way of the
chakras up to the top of the Skool where
Shiva dwells unites with him the
yogan through powerful techniques of
sexual spiritual meditation is thus
transformed into a kind of
androgyny in Buddhism also the true
human the archetype is
androgynous these yogic practices and
mystical teachings concerning androgyny
are doubtless as old as the Mesopotamian
and Syrian
kinds now here's where it comes really
full circle people alra Crowley
practiced three to four forms of yoga
daily to prepare for invocation and
rituals with the demons that's insane
okay there is good reason to believe
that a form of ancient gnosticism namely
hermeticism survived and influenced the
medieval West through my through the
mystical spirituality of alchemy this
variant Egyptian version of no NOS nosis
sorry saw in Hermes the Divine
interpreter
whose Secrets enable man to pass through
various levels of reality thus making
esoteric mutations
possible the spiritual Alchemist became
an initiate one who knows as the ancient
gnostics knew so now they want to be
like the annaki Y okay like Hermes the
AR aramel mercuries was understood as a
kind of divine other who would intervene
by creating the resolution of opposites
while no explicit sexual perversion is
promoted joining of the Opposites or
Union was frequently IM imaged as hyro
remember the wiccan great right yeah a
holy marriage they call it the fruit of
which is called the Philosopher's Stone
you should be thinking Freemasonry the
philosopher stone yeah this fruit they
call it is sometimes called the child of
the work which is presented as the
Hermetic androgyny under the rubric two
in one at the very least we have to
reckon here with a spiritualized form of
what a ladies calls ritual
androgenization so they're actually
giving you the definition this is when
you actually do a sexual act yeah of not
carrying you know just any sexual act
with anybody that's the pan sexual this
is crazy like this one slide has so much
in it because I
know this is the world we're at you you
look at these pag or you look at these
Pride parades and like it said in the
article um even though maybe these
sexual acts aren't performed
openly it's like it's all the
celebration of it I mean it's gotten so
bad that when you go to these parades
you see
men making a circle around young boys
and throwing money at them as the young
boy shaking his butt and
it's and they're saying this is a
familyfriendly event that this is all
about love and all this stuff and all
this is going on and that's what I'm
getting at when you have a church flying
that flag you know that the deception is
so
great that you're not even allowed to
tell the truth this video might get
pulled down might get censored by
YouTube because you're sharing
historical facts that this is paganism
and
satanic it's not just an alternate style
it's not just an alternate lifestyle of
love like we have to
stop sugarcoating this because it's that
dangerous it's that demonic and yet
Christians still want to tiptoe around
this subject and invite it into the
church I mean when I I took a picture of
that church I could not believe what I
was seeing and this is the day and age
we're living in when a Christian Church
basically says come bring your demons in
mhm I I I agree that you should always
have your doors open to anybody a
prostitute an occultist have that church
doors open for anyone but do not fly a
flag in and saying that we approve of
this lifestyle you don't allow them to
come do their rituals or bring their
paraphernalia right or their altar with
them or their attitude I can't go into
the church and fire up a joint and drink
a beer they're going to kick you out
right so you have to leave that
lifestyle outside when you come in yeah
so I think it was interesting I want to
make a point of this real
quick you had
mentioned
um well on several accounts we've
mentioned like the Catholic church and
um if you're not sure that lines up you
can always read 50 years in the Church
of Rome okay it's a priest who came out
of Catholicism who tells you what
happened to him in the
dormitories as a young priest in short
he found that one night he was going to
bed and a different man climbed in bed
with him and he shouted and screamed get
out of my bed and the priest that was
like the head priest maybe I don't know
the Father the superior father that was
like in charge of the dormatory came
running and he goes shame on you how
could you refuse such brotherly love
from another wow that's insane and he
thought to himself this is is homosexual
Behavior we don't do this and truly what
love meant to
them was that this is love to them yeah
not regular heterosexual love of of
God's deeper nature as well where it's
you know I will give my life for you and
he gave his life in Salvation it was all
homosexual
rituals drinking all of that stuff none
of the stuff that we as Protestants
should be doing advocating for and the
saying that everyone wants to say now is
Love Is
Love it's not true anything goes if I
love that dog or I love that little
child where do you draw a line when you
say when you agree with Love Is Love
because hey if you if you're a man and
you love a man it's
love well what if you love someone
that's underage or
another you know another species yeah
when you when you're not when you can
identify as anything you want they got
kids literally they have children in
public schools peeing in litter
boxes because if they refuse to
recognize that this kid identifies as a
cat then you can be locked up we live in
Bizarro world where the mental people of
the world Rule and if you don't if you
don't turn from RE reality and accept
they
the mental Insanity yeah it's like The
Emperor's New Clothes right if if you
don't see the clothes on the naked man
walking down the street then you just
you're not blessed enough to be able to
see you're not privileged enough to be
able to see the clothes and we live in a
new type
of rich man's clothes The Emperor's New
Clothes where if you don't recognize my
son's a cat you're the problem yeah and
you need to be locked
up anyway yes um so we're going to talk
more about this because as we come up to
the
real occult stuff going on here it says
in the same illuminous tradition Jacob
boham again he's the occult
writer a great Mystic and he's called a
great Mystic and Proto theosophist
believed Adam was androgynous and the
sexist appeared as a result of the Fall
oh my goodness for this
monistic Mystic the ideal human state
was androgyny according to a lady bamy
delivered these Notions not from the
cabala all of a sudden the cabala is
mentioned yeah interesting but from
Alchemy for he makes use of alal terms
one of his spiritual
successors France Von B postulated the
androgyny had existed at the beginning
meaning Adam and would appear again at
the end of time well here it is one
notable inheritor of the esoteric
movements of alchemy and her hermeticism
in the modern world is philosophy I'm
sorry I should say I said that terribly
wrong theosophy it is not without
interest that Madame blotsky founder of
the Theo
the theosophical society yeah thank you
towards the end of the 19th century May
well have had a dominatrix lesbian
relationship with her success Annie
bassant bassant became began public life
as the wife of an an Anglican Minister
became a birth control propag
propagandist and then an occultist wow
later theosophists such as aliser
Crowley promoter of the occultist Pagan
hermetic Order of the Golden Dawn as
well as
Charles Leed beater whom blavatsky
called her Bishop were noted homo sexual
predus or pedophiles wow I had to look
that word up because they didn't give
that I put that there they had to
sugarcoat it there is good reason to
think that such activity was not the
expression of personal weakness but the
consistent expression of pagan
spirituality Victor Newberg homosexual
sex magic he did this he was the guy who
um it says right there is Led Zeppelin's
singer or um sorry he's not that guy he
basically owned this house oh yeah where
all the sex magic happened it called
it's called The Bull skin house which
was later bought by
aliser um because of all the memorabilia
in it Led Zeppelin singer Jimmy pagee
was interested in it and Alistar created
the top
selling um tho tarot cards remember we
talked about him y he put the K in magic
for Sex Magic that's what the k means
yeah and influenced Gerald Gardner
heavily he's the father of Witchcraft
and the founder of Wiccan religion
wow so this all comes to to Circle um to
come together
because it's all about the sexuality
yeah of people for meter mule a
businessman who became involved in
spiritualism founded the goats spund
Tantra that's that's the important word
there home of Jacob
boham members wore the
gods I eye badge and believed that
homosexuals
were vocationally
mediums they also with a certain logical
consistency held that heterosexual
intercourse impaired the mediumistic
talent oh my goodness this small detail
of Germanic occult history is
significant since leading contemporary
homosexuals make the same
claims
interesting without any apparent
dependence on the theories of mule such
parallel thinking would suggest an
organic connection between homosexuality
and shamanistic religious activity so
what they're saying is if you want to be
a medium if you want to be a shaman if
you want to be a witch one with the
universe all that stuff yeah if you have
heter seexual sex you're actually really
hindering your abilities yes which is
why I I mean it verifies what I've
noticed and recognized for a long time
that homosexuality and Witchcraft go
hand in hand yes and when you know when
we would speak out against Witchcraft
and movies and cartoons and things like
that we would get flooded with different
people saying be gay do witchcraft be
gay and do witchcraft yeah so there's a
whole lot of people out there that
realize that this is a lifestyle that
goes hand in hand you go to the satanic
festivals you're going to see a lot of
homosexual stuff there you're going to
see a lot of gay flags and stuff you go
to the gay parades you're going to see a
lot of satanic stuff horns and making
fun of Jesus and all these things and
the wck goes hand hand yeah the witches
will be there so yes this is is bringing
it closer and closer I hope the dots are
connecting the bells are going off but I
just realized something that I didn't
mention so Victor Newberg was actually
aliser Crawley's assistant okay at this
bull skin house where they did the sex
magic yeah and before that you we we
read that um alist cley was doing three
to four um types of Yoga each morning to
connect with the demons right before
doing the sex magic he was hoping to
take like a whole year to learn how to
do sex magic to connect with the
demons really well right to another
level of Enlightenment
basically when he came across Victor
they were in the middle of doing a lot
of other rituals that were sexual and
crappy and all of a sudden
apparently he's written in his diary you
can read about it whatever but he pulls
Victor in and starts doing the
homosexual acts on him and it actually
sped up everything like 10 steps wow so
no longer do you have to do this this
this and this just participate in the
homosexual act and you're already there
with the demon communing wow and it
unfortunately did um Victor was the same
age but they started learning that the
younger the child is
the better for that as well results that
they would get yeah wow so that's
because you're pleasing Satan yeah you
you want to get and that's why you find
out that all these things these Elite
parties where they're literally eating
feces they are eating cake in the shape
of humans and humans which might have
blood in it or something yeah and
wearing masks and just having sex with
anybody the more debaucherous it is the
more that's right anti the more
lawlessness it is you know God says this
comes out of you for a reason it's waste
don't consume it but the more you do
things that go against God's Perfect
Design the happier you make Satan and
the more he's like I will bless you if
you can if you sin in the most
disgusting ways I'll bless you we're God
says look if you do it my way you will
be blessed because my way is the only
way right you don't it's it's not like
I'm going to give you a blessing because
you're doing the right thing it's just
when you do the right thing you are
blessed because that's the natural
outcome but Satan is rewarding people
for for sinning for creating new ways to
sin the Bible talks about I don't
remember if it was Sodom gamorra or
Babel or what but they were inventing
new ways to sin
yeah
so I to say it but it's going to go a
little
deeper and I have it right there it's
the the small text in white
block in the white block it says because
we have to understand this we have to
understand that it's not just a sexual
act it's the Hierro it's the marrying of
the two the holy act we want to actually
know why the whole Alchemy part oh yeah
at this cuz this is which Alchemy is uh
chemical Magic it's science and sorcery
together right thank you for describing
that in some alel illustrations
especially coming from Alistar cley's
book that's why I have it shown there
the androgyny is labeled Rebus or resb I
mentioned that before which meant two
thing or double thing it is also called
her hermaphrodite or androgyny of the
wise which is conceived from the
coupling of the male which is sulfur and
the female mercury elements these two
opposite yet
uh complimentary elements went into the
mercal bath and produced the male and
female in a single body they
say so here's where we kind of get this
whole I don't
know reptilian looking idea so a shaman
is a charged potent all inspiring and
even fear inspiring person who takes
true risks by crossing over into other
worlds a a fuller definition leaves
little to the imagination the power and
the effectiveness of shamans witches
cels Druids emerges from the ability to
communicate with the non-human
extraterrestrial and Subterranean forces
and the spirit world of the Dead this is
happening today by the way like there's
so many people that believe in aliens
communicate with supposed
aliens we are like this we're living in
the last days that's all I can say this
woman ver Virginia Mullen cot calling
herself an Evangelical lesbian feminist
oh my goodness speaks for gays and
lesbians when she says we are God's
ambassadors indeed she claims she was
told by her guardian angel a spirit
guide the Holy Spirit or Jesus she's not
sure of course it didn't come out of the
word of God came from an angel right a
great shift is occurring in the world
and you are a part of that shift for
Rosemary Radford Ruther a leading
Christian feminist the Theologian and
rogy is her model for a human species
liberated from dualistic gender into
psychic wholeness oh my similarly Judy
Wester dorf a United Methodist clergy
woman now we have a church
woman in leadership triumphantly
declares to the delegates of the Pagano
Christian feminist reimagining
conference in Minneapolis that the
church has always been blessed by gays
and lesbians witches and shamans who so
he she's actually putting it in terms of
what it is
gays warlocks or Shaman yeah lesbians
witches yeah no doubt without much
awareness of these elitist theories and
the Deep spiritual Stakes involved the
media has shaped the sexually fantasy
world sexual fantasy world of America's
youth this is what they're really
getting at yeah so let's continue here's
I guess where it all comes to the
Catholic church and a lot of things
in the ancient this is looks like the
coexist it is there you go because the
Catholic Church there only one form hold
yeah they hold these uhhuh uh meetings
where all the leaders of the world
different religions come together and we
should all just get along and we can we
all serve the same God we all serve love
and all
this so yeah go ahead okay in the
ancient Gnostic texts such connections
can be detected the Catholic Church
Father hippolytus documents how and why
the spiritual gnostics did not hesitate
to imitate Pagan spirituality and
sexuality in one form or another he
explains the Gnostic nine participation
in the cult of the Goddess because they
claimed that everything is spiritual the
nines did not become GLE physically but
rather spiritually so they they wanted
to worship the goddess but they didn't
want to castrate themselves okay they
only perform the functions of those who
are castrated by abstaining from sexual
intercourse okay so concludes hippolytus
hippo yeah litis the nine gnostics
imitate the gley the castrated Priests
of cbel for they urge most severely and
carefully that one should abstain as
those men The Galley do from intercourse
with women their behavior otherwise is
like that of the castrated the
mythological story of a castration of
Addis thus led the NES to conclude the
IM of emasculation was a symbol of
Salvation Addis cut off his testicles in
order to break with the baser and
material world and gain access to
Immortal Life where there is no longer
either male or female oh my these
Christian again Christian gnostics
sought through a deeper form of
spiritual androgyny a close association
with paganism understanding of Sal
salvation of what does such salvation
consist the Gnostic Gospel of Truth
announ annunci the theory it is within
Unity that each one will attain himself
within knowledge he will purify himself
from multiplicity into Unity the Gospel
of Thomas they say develops the
Practical
consequences s uh Simon Peter said to
them let Mary go away from us for women
are not worthy of Life Jesus said they
say that yeah lo I shall lead her so
that I may make her a male that she too
may become a Living spirit resembling
you
males for every woman who makes herself
a male will enter the kingdom of heaven
so the males have to cut off their
testicles but the females have to become
male yeah here apparently is the road of
Salvation the mystical attainment of an
androgynous or sexless State this
professor perceives in The Alchemist
quest for gold again a blueprint for the
planet's future hallagan notes that the
second of the seven stages of Alchemist
um
Alchemist meditation called
solutio involves both a transformation
of sexual energy and the destruction of
the individual's ego or self this is a
powerful mystical experience of pure
monistic monistic spirituality for this
Roman Catholic scholar monism seems to
present no problem but the process is
far from Over the seventh stage
conjunctio or joining is a new reality
the final bring together of all the
Opposites producing gold spiritual gold
a tremendously deepened sense of the
Oneness of
all
unitive uh Consciousness is awareness of
the essential Oneness with the Divine
they say that is Mystic
Consciousness the unification of all the
Opposites within oneself hallan's final
def definition of the conjunctio is
clear Beyond gender differences now the
mystics of each eastern and western
tradition describe the Bliss of Abiding
Love as we can see from this mystical
and alche background some believe that
Jesus was androgynous oh my just an
androgynous ascended
master so Satan's plan for Humanity is
to make everyone
non-binary and ultimately unable to
reproduce and the Earth will
depopulate and he will promise those who
are the elites of the world that they
can have eternal life through
technology science and all that but
really he's just convinced the world to
depopulate
itself and and do
it for religious purposes like we're
doing this out of love and unity and we
are raising our consciousness we're
reach we're we're reaching Christ
Consciousness by becoming non-binary
we're becoming one with the universe
basically we have to because our genders
are different we need to become the same
yeah and unite and become Universal and
all this stuff it's insane yes but
there's more to this gold and this
Hierro and the ritual unfortunately so
they talked about a lot of monism we
need to know what monism is does monism
believe in God it says monism believes
that all things in existence are part of
the same unified Oneness some monists
call us God believing that there is one
God and that God is in all things
however other monists call this unified
Oneness something else other than God
such as the universe The Source nature
or other names so it's anything just all
roads lead to God right everything's
everything it's the it is the coexist
that's why I have it there and this is
the symbol just a circle with a dot in
it is the monism symbol yeah it looks
similar it's where we find this this
symbol for Rebus okay the
androgyny that's right there that's the
whole horned okay person Marilyn Manson
used that on one of his albums now I
know why oh okay because when he came
out with Mechanical Animals album he uh
had a body suit on that made him look
like a woman and that was it was weird
but yeah I see he he was pushing the
whole trans movement back
then yeah so it says moving from a
metaphysical analysis to a more
spiritual Outlook monism is the
underlying worldview of those who hold a
form of pantheism pantheism is a
worldview that God not necessarily
Christian God is the ultimate source of
being that all of reality is a
manifestation of this God in all
different forms and manifestations
pantheism sees no real distinction
between God and the universe plot is
from that time period the father of neop
platonian plais or Plato ISM was a
popular pantheist his brand of
metaphysics taught that ultimate being
resided in the
one from a series of necessary
emanations out of the one comes the
Divine mind the next level of emanation
results in the world's Soul or psyche
and finally the material world Cosmos
another famous
philosophical pantheist was a 7th
Century rationalist philosopher 1th
Century thank you 17th century
rationalist philosopher baroo Spinosa I
don't know why he's mentioned exactly
but there's a reason why all of this is
happening they
say this is why it matters so much this
is really what we're getting
at miray e both a remarkable researcher
of the phenomenon of pagan spirituality
says
she explains the spiritual meaning of
androgyny sorry we're jumping around a
little as a symbolic restoration of
chaos the undifferentiated unity that
precedes the creation preceded the
creation the androgynous being
thus thus sums up the very goal of the
mystical mon monistic Quest whether
ancient or modern in mystical love and
at death one completely integrates the
spirit world all contraries are
collapsed the distinctions between the
Sexes are erased the two emerge into an
androgynous ho in short at the center
one knows oneself is known and knows the
nature of reality or again according to
a lady arogy androgyny is in many
traditional religious functions is an
archal and Universal formula for the
expression of wholeness the coexistence
of the contraries or coincidentia
oppositorum symbolizing perfection and
the ultimate being the androgyny is thus
the physical symbol of the Pagan
spiritual goal which is the merging of
two seemingly distinct entities the self
and God and a mystical return to the
state of godhead prior to Creation the
joining of the Opposites is the
disillusion of creational distinctions
and thus the destruction of Creations
hold upon human
identity such joining brings a
liberating recognition that the real
self is
uncreated so you are God and you create
yourself that's right that's what they
believe the solution of our angst
according to a feminist author is
healing through the sacred marriage
again this
Hierro she said it right there actually
Hierro this is the marriage of the ego
and the self which gives birth to a
divine child the child of the work or
the philosopher stone I want you to get
used to these terms because they use
them and then you you know what they're
saying right that's why I say them and
have them in here so many times a woman
gives birth to herself as a Divine
androgynous being autonomous and in a
state of perfection in the unity of
opposites she is whole pleasure as
prayer so here we go sexual pleasure is
prayer oh my goodness a Transcendent
experience beyond the polarity of
genders and to give birth within oneself
to a mental or spiritual androgyny the
goal is a merger at the point of orgasm
which transcends Division and which in
an ecstatic feedback returns and
reinforces and then dissolves the
essence of both
sexes so here's where we need to
understand also the origin and meaning
of
transubstantiation
because they say it comes from Mystery
of the Eucharist from Osiris cakes which
then became known as Jesus
Wafers yeah so the doctrine of
transubstantiation came from the not
from the Last Supper but actually from
Trans
transubstantiation in Pagan religions in
Egypt priests would consecrate cakes
which were supposed to become the Flesh
of Osiris the idea of transubstantiation
was also characteristic of the religion
of Mithra whose sacraments of cakes and
homoa drink closely parallels the
Catholic Eucharist rights it was a
converted topic for many centuries
before officially becoming an Article of
Faith which means it is essential to
Salvation according to the Roman
Catholic Church the ritual of eating a
cornbread representing the body of
Osiris and the drinking of beer or wine
representative of Osiris's Osiris
conceptualization as The God Who taught
Egyptians to make barley and wine in
short became Rewritten into the story of
The Last Supper and the eating and
drinking of the body and blood of Jesus
Christ and the concept of
transubstantiation is that interesting
in light of the new Olympics thing
because there's an argument whether it's
the mockery of the last supper or if
it's the it's an ancient
Greek
painting
but there was something mentioned here
oh for one this is why you're not really
supposed to drink alcohol alcohol I mean
the Catholic Church they drink the wine
the fermented alcoholic wine which is
exact ritual here and they turn the
supposedly they turn the wafer into the
literal fles of Christ which is
cannibalism and so it's it's openly and
in your face that they are practicing
this occult practice whereas the
true
um
communion is bread and Juice like Jesus
did with his
disciples um something else that was
mentioned in here it
says what did it say man I just oh I
can't remember what it was there was a
mention of something that I see in our
world
today but I can't remember what it was
something to do with I lost it man that
was the second time it got mentioned
though
a it's okay go ahead so we want to know
not just it's not just fun to know where
trans the term transubstantiation and
practice of it came from I know what it
was the ego death oh that is something
that people are doing now more than ever
with Mt and all the iasa and all this
yeah they say that um when they have
this trip for one they blast out of
their body into the universe they
usually see deities whether it be a
bluefaced goddess woman or whatever but
when they come back they're like forever
changed they say it's a life-changing
experience and they call the ego death
and that's I saw that mentioned here and
somewhere else yes yes
so here's where it truly gets into
transubstantiation is from wiah that's
really where it's from the Osiris was
the goddess who was bringing witchcraft
to the Egyptians and the cultures around
it because it says I'll just read what
it says this is also interconnected with
wiah how one may transfer the presence
of a god or goddess or materialization
of them to objects if not their own
bodies to be used directly
as a token of ritual participation for
the gods or spirits to enter them it
also is mentioned as transubstantiation
I found this right on their
website in the case of hos G if you
aren't the male and female taking on the
form or role of Priestess and high
priest all bystanders are said to
participate mentally and symbolically
allowing the gods to enter you freely as
you feel and take part through the
ritual by mentally placing yourself in
the place of the participant wow some
also carry this out by themselves
through masturbation or with a friend no
gender boundaries are kept and not only
biological males can play the the male
part or vice versa food items such as
Wafers bread or cakes historically and
biblically are used to trans
transubstantiate the Gods in the body to
possess it through part partaking of it
after calling the god into
it that's exactly what the Catholic
Church does yes some Wiccan rituals
include the sharing of cakes and Ale
symbolizing the union union of the god
and goddess or the balance of masculine
and feminine energies cakes and Ale are
often served at celebratory rituals and
shared among attendees today most cakes
served as celebration at celebrations
are often cookies in the shape of
Crescent moons or fun shapes like booms
and bats Broms I think is yeah so the
Crescent Moon is supposed to symbolize
um the fertility rights and usually the
feminine part of alchemy and in God
goddesses just a fun fact there ale
isn't necessarily an alcoholic drink
always it's of it can often be a fruit
juice or non-alcoholic cider or even
water fun fact long ago water was once
referenced as Adam's ale to them oh as
it was the only drink available to Adam
in the Garden of Eden this comes from a
wicked
Source Ro um Roberto caloso's discussion
of
Hierro hierogamy and sacrifice in the
marriage of Cadmus and Harmony May
provide insight into the continuing
thread of experience from the Greek
model of the wicked practice the
appearance of the world came about with
the culation here we go of a god with
that which was not God with the
laceration and dispersal of God's body
through sex life and in life necessity
the necessity to kill and eat and to
experience loss and pain life constantly
is guilty of causing death a guilt that
must be
expiated Hami is akin to sacrifice
offering up although tempor um
temporarily one's body and spirit as a
gift to the gods for their use the
parallels between blood and sexual
fluids the equation and connection of
life and death Sex and Death eating and
sex all layer underneath the experience
of H hierogamy the fact that humans and
gods copulated at the beginning of
everything creates a connection between
humanity and the Divine a kinship so
again this this is what they believe
yeah we share lust sexual passion we can
remind ourselves of our fundamental
relationship in each sexual act with
orgasm we can project our Consciousness
back to the Primal moment of creation
that's insane but this journey back to
the beginning is dangerous and threatens
to erase the boundaries between human
and divine permanently to collapse the
universe back into Primal
Disorder so we sacrifice which reminds
both parties of the absolute
distinctions of life and death between
gods and humans sacrifice however seen
as an aspect of sex tying life and death
together much as the great story of the
maiden goddess of springing persone in
her H rogamos with the god of death the
underworld pluton or Hades brings Sex
and Death together sexual fluids like
amorita and Sean being produced and
sacrificed from the body and like blood
being tied to life itself are perfect
for this purpose wow Waldo Emerson here
we're coming a little closer to every
day
things he wrote that this I'm sorry they
wrote about him this s Sac sacred
marriage expresses what occurs in
particular on the moral plane the Pagan
monest assumes Guiltless responsibility
for his actions whether good or evil and
thus in an exercise of personal
autonomous power joins the Opposites of
Good and Evil the early American monest
Ralph Ralph Waldo Emerson he was a
writer by the way if you didn't know a
famous writer welcomed this spiritual
option with enthusiasm he says if I am
the Devil's Child I will live then from
the devil no law can be sacred to me
with that of my nature good and bad are
but names very readily transfer
transferable to this or that the
deliberate Act of power which defiantly
declares evil good and good evil lies in
the face of the Creator's design
and in so doing jumps into the waiting
arms of the
tempter yeah one may well wonder if this
joining of the Opposites is a possible
implication of the Serpent's words
knowing good and evil yep I was just
thinking of that verse about they call
evil good and good
evil so now we have today we have all
these personality types that this psych
psychoanalyst or psychologist CJ Jung
came up with he says under the influence
of filimon a familiar spirit
he has a a diary where he says that he
wrote his famous seven sermons to the
dead using colorful imagery Jung
disavows Christianity and endorses Pagan
spirituality employing the pseudonim of
ballades a famous second century Gnostic
heretic Jung addresses the spirits of
dead Crusaders who had failed to find
Salvation in Jerusalem he succeeds in
converting them to the Gnostic God Abra
AIS who is both good and evil a terrible
hidden God that humans cannot perceive
braxis is behind the Sun and night the
creator of and destroyer of the world
truth and evil light and darkness the
hermaphrodite of the earliest
beginning the operation of all the gods
and devils and is the world is the world
it's becoming and passing Jung ends his
sermon with a call to look at the God
within rather than the Christian God of
the Bible in this regard it is
appropriate to recall the definition of
the mystical goal believed to be in all
religions given by Yale Professor Louise
Dupri a state in which all distinctions
disappear wow all
distinctions yes that's what they want
just fluidity so this is
him Carl Carl Yong Yong Jong whatever on
the second plane this homosexual
androgyny according to Jung affirms his
power by willingly assuming his physical
proclivities and thus joining what God
has put us under wow indeed for Jung
spiritual and drogyny symbolizes the
integration of the Opposites or the
state of individuation of the autonomous
individual Jung himself suggested that
homosexuality preserved an archetype or
archetype of the androgynous original
person that is why homosexuals can
propose themselves to society as
shamans the monistic tradition
the same religious claim is made for
homosexuality as is made for androgyny
since both androgyny and homosexuality
function religiously and traditional
paganism they are clearly related the
same emphasis is found in Carl
heinrich's
often considered the grandfather of the
modern gay rights
movement in his claims olrick rejected
all psychological and behavioral
explanations of homosexuality and
adopted a psych spiritual one he
believed a homosexual was a man's body
inhabited by a woman's Soul or vice
versa for a lesbian notice the spiritual
terminology he calls he called
homosexuality a third sex that is a true
expression of
androgyny which is like the ultimate
goal of these pagans and
occultists yeah so we already read this
part actually from the queer um
magicians and stuff and saying that
they have a special power of medicine
and magic and they
are this is an important part right here
actually the very bottom the separation
between humans animals and plants have
been eliminated and at that point
full-blown monistic Union Union ensues
blending is another way of speaking of
spiritual union with the all they don't
want a distinction even between animals
right that's where all this furry junk
comes in
yeah so here's where
a video comes in okay
okay uh oh we
have we don't have sound on the video I
remember that was an issue before really
so yeah you want just explain it okay so
he's talking about Michael Jackson and
how Michael Jackson really wowed us he
took our hearts
he
um made our emotions sore through his
music he was amazing at his dance we we
truly truly became Carried Away by him
if you liked him I don't know if you do
but he kind of took over the whole world
yeah with his amazing stuff and um he's
speaking a church and how many people
are a fan of Michael Jackson's music and
his dancing and everything and it says
he's talking about how much we actually
defend Michael Jackson his music and
everything his lyrics all this stuff and
when it really comes down to
it I'm jumping way ahead but this is
kind of awesome because he actually
finds out Michael Jackson was emulating
Corey bontes one of the types of
androgynous
priests oh wow of a certain culture yeah
remember when I mentioned that that they
dance and they have shrieks while they
dance y yes he was one of those and they
had pale skin and long hair and he
purposely did that to himself you look
at old pictures of Michael back when the
Jackson 5 he was black skinned wide nose
afro I mean he was like your typical
African-American yeah but he did all
that to look like one of these whatever
what is it Cory bontes yeah so there you
go you have it there
um this is the cool part when he jumps
to this you can actually
see eventually he gives you a definition
and that definition is
amazing because it shows the the white
skin the curly hair cut that way the
kind of
dancing and ripping clothes off and
everything like it was just they used to
dance and stuff right yeah there we go
worshippers of the Goddess cybel they
had their hair dressed and waved hair
dressed and waved like women they were
heavily made up their faces resembling
whitewashed walls they were castrated
and keepers of children and infants
partaking in Coming of Age rituals and
celebrations they also practiced magic
and divination to make money they made
wild cries or high-pitched shrills while
they performed their dances to the music
of the pipes and the dull beat of the
tambourine when the deity entered into
them they were possessed by divine power
they would dance uncontrollably wow that
is insane and that's that's literally
what he did you know we know you know
from experience as a hip-hop dancer in
the past yeah that the music would take
over you and you would um dance you'd be
possessed by the music
basically and so that that was crazy uh
everything was a perfect match to
Michael Jackson even the keeper of
children he had his house turned into a
theme park called Never Never Land where
you're never supposed to grow up and he
had kids spend the night at his house
and play on the the theme park and
everything uh yeah it's really crazy the
high pitch shrills and
[Music]
everything so here's where man it really
comes down to it these are other people
again stating from their claims of being
gay that they share the sentiments of a
radical feminist Theologian who says
religious imp pulses are being killed by
traditional
judeo-christianity her name is Clark and
she seems to be saying that the problem
lies not with men mean-spirited or
hateful Christians failing to be true
loving
Christians or sorry failing to be true
and loving Christians for gays the
problem lies rather with the whole
biblical world view and Theological
Paradigm yeah it has to we surely must
conclude that sexual perversion and in
particular the elimination of sexual
distinctions is is not an incidental
footnote of pagan religious history of
mere passing interest but represents one
of its fundamental ideological
commitments that the Pagan priesthood
would be so identified across space and
time with the blurring of sexual
identity via homosexual androgyny
indicates Beyond a doubt the enormous
priority paganism has given and
continues to give to the undermining of
God ordained monogamous heter
sexuality and the enthusiastic promotion
of androgyny in its varied
forms so here again we come across the
alal
symbols that was a powerful statement I
mean is that was that from a
non-Christian Source did that all come
from Alchemy website.com
no okay but it did come from a huge
source that is it's cited down below I
mean I don't even I mean this the most
powerful quote there is it's saying
that you know it's not just a mere
footnote basically is what it said like
when when people are changing genders
and saying they're non-binary and all
these things it's not just like oh you
know who else used to do that in the
past no it originated from paganism the
occult from Satanism he's the creator of
confusion he's the author of confusion
he's the one that wants to pervert
everything God made everything God
designed sexuality
male and female
um heterosexuality all this stuff
procreation this lifestyle is not just
something you can say you know what some
people they were like that but they're
not like that now this is where it's a
deception you've gotten involved in the
occult without being aware of it y
That's what Satan does he deceives he
traps he snares all these terms that the
Bible says resist the devil he will flee
from you but when you Embrace these
things you will be trapped and ins
snared and
deceived and it all it it's not
something we can excuse it's not
something we can
say uh you know it's okay it's Love Love
Is Love let people love who they want to
love this is satanic hands down yeah um
and so when we come across this and the
alal symbols that right that are right
there
if you see the male and female which
they claimed was
Mercury as the
female
and uh I think it's Men Are from Mars
Women Are from Venus right yeah but it
didn't work that way in alamy it's
sulfur and Mercury oh that cross and
become the Sun or gold so it becomes uh
planets and elements in alchemy go and
it says it right there actually I should
have just read that but that's the
symbol you become is that dotted head
horned being and you also become in
unison with spiritual monism like we
said it's all religions are the same y
pantheism at the highest so it says
sulfur is the masculine principal mer
Mercury the female sulfur and Mercury
are also equivalent to soul and Luna so
the Sun and the Moon sulfur being fiery
and active representing the sun while
Mercury being liquid and passive is the
moon thus the idea rose that sulfur may
be identified with gold or treated as
the prime matter of Soul all of a sudden
it's the prime matter of the Sun the
solar gold making it's what they call it
wow and Islamic Theory Mercury and
sulfur are the parents of metals
according to this Theory Mercury is
generally regarded as cold and moist but
the liquid component of
metals being the liquid component of
metals while sulfur is hot and dry being
the solid excuse me being the solid
material
component so here's some more quotes and
things we have all these people saying
this they they basically had to have the
funeral of God and The Rebirth of gods
and goddesses of ancient Greece and Rome
why because they want happening like at
the at these events every time they have
a worldwide event when all the eyes of
the world are on it whether it's right
the
euro vision what is it the euro Music
Awards or
the I can't even remember the names of
these things but we've done videos on
them where they have these Olympic type
events Super Bowl and the Olympics and
all these things they openly do these
rituals where they have Bulls come out
and they bow down to them and they hold
up crystals and they're openly doing
they're they're desensitizing you to the
satanic practices by making it look like
entertainment
and the whole world is watching and
applauding and approving when the Bible
says in
Romans uh 132 it says not only those who
do the acts of sin are worthy of death
but those who are entertained by it who
approve of those that do it so with if
you say you're an
ally I've heard people say I'm a gay
Ally I'm not gay but I'm an ally you're
just as guilty as being The Sinner if
you say I'm not a witch but I love Harry
Potter you're just as guilty at when you
entertain your mind with sin Jesus said
sin starts in the
mind to look upon a woman to lust after
her is the same as committing adultery
in your heart right to be angry and hate
your brother without a cause is the same
as
murder and so the we can't excuse these
things and and this is why it's so
important to talk about this topic to
get to the bottom of this the root of
this thing because ignor ignorance is
causing people to fall for these
deceptions right Satan doesn't want us
to know history Satan you know history
repeats itself and if you don't know
history you're doomed to repeat history
right and that's what's happening
but it's important for us to know so
that we don't fall for these
deceptions so I'm just G to get down to
the the red part here it's a Roman
Catholic scholar who writes
the God God does not have to die he
simply has to undergo a sex change
unfortunately he also had to change
religion and take up Abode in the Pagan
Pantheon so um next part
here they are talking about Lennon's
imagine full of Hope For A New World
Order of unity and love respect and
democracy we have brought across that
bridge the agenda of the ideal
androgynous sexually unfettered new men
or new man of pagan
spirituality so they're looking for the
new age to occur that's what they're
they're looking
for they declare that says something at
the very oh I'll just read it at the
very moment when the new age gurus
declar the imminent arrival of the age
of Aquarius the 18th century theosophist
batter's prophecy seems to be appearing
the return of the original androgyny wow
yeah and they are theyve been saying
this for a while since the 60s the the
age of Aquarius is upon us
yeah so you can look over this a little
bit we'll just get quick into this these
Styles and fashion of actually looking
androgynous has started way back when
with those uh this particular actress I
forget I don't know her name I'm pretty
young so I don't
know and this particular um model or or
prominent person in what was the
Bloomers the first Bloomers or pants
that was worn and then wearing just full
suits so we have that and today we have
plenty of this going on in Chanel and
all the different kinds of people here
now I remember when you didn't see women
wearing pants and it was like a big deal
and women start wearing pants and
burning their bra and all this stuff but
now it's like oh men can't wear dresses
I'll show you we're going to do it you
know it's just like the spirit of
Rebellion thing yeah so they mentioned
in the the second text box there that we
can't look over Elvis Presley who wore
face
makeup and a feminite guy kind of um
dress clothing really like the Sparkles
blingy yeah yeah yeah so they're
actually saying that was more
androgynous um then you have Rolling
Stone performances MC Jagger wearing a
man's a man's dress type of thing um you
have Jimmy hen HRI his choice of wearing
women's blouses and high heels Jimmy
Hendrick yeah interesting um David Bowie
his alter ego
Ziggy Ziggy Stardust the Persona was
introduced to the public when David
launched his
album um when asked to De detail on the
Persona he was embodying David
describing himself as a reflection of
his sexual
ambiguity so um you do have we're
skipping down to the last one here
basically you've got a bunch of these
models actresses famous stars who have
their own clothing line now for
androgynous looks or neutral gender
neutral looks right how many of these
celebrities do you see that are like
raising their kids yeah like boys
wearing dresses and all that this
happens all the time it's true yeah and
some of them um I'll just skip to the
very bottom is Lady Gaga Ruby Rose who's
the model up in the far right Lily Rose
Depp and Jaden Smith they all have their
own clothing lines that do this it's
supposedly strictly androgynous yeah
this is like the New World Order fashion
coming yeah and here's a few LeBron
James in his pink skirt I think that's
his name yeah and zanda in a suit like
you know and here's a bunch of pictures
why because I just wanted to show you
this is Twiggy on the far left on the
top Twiggy was the like one of the first
models to be ideal in all of her
features and she all of a sudden has all
these suits that she's dressed
in um K-pop stars and everything Jaden
Smith in his his black skirt there yeah
um
so there's a few pictures where it's
Lady Gaga actually right there in the
black and white picture with the smoking
the cigarette yeah that is Lady Gaga and
her Persona her oh my good Alter Ego I
forgot what his name is but that's
her and you have you know Brad Pit on
the bottom is this P Diddy right there
Kanye Kanye okay in a
skirt um LeBron James again in a maid's
outfit you have this uh famous I don't
know what his name is but it's a famous
model's husband that's pictures of him
both of them are him oh wow and then you
got Kesha all these people are up here
because I found out that they are
admitting to being one thing or another
bisexual transgender pantheistic you
name it just gay lesbian whatever and so
I added them and here's more pictures
just proof B Billy
ish
um what is his name that's right there
from a fast and furious I'm not sure
that one but there um oh yeah from Fast
and Furious serous this one vend diesel
there you go diesel yeah you have Ann
Hathaway right there she looks like a
man like she just straight up and pink
is always looked very masculine that
right there with her her daughter is
even wearing that and her husband of
course demy levado has always gone back
and forth with her gender you have all
these people um Megan Fox being bisexual
like Jay-Z down there with a plaid skirt
yep you got Fergie dressed in a suit on
the very bottom bottom left
um what's up with Snoop Dogg he says
he's gay oh my yeah it doesn't really
surprise me just because any everybody
in the industry now they they are right
but we got all these people Miley Cyrus
right there in her blue plaid shirt I
think that's what it is flannel sorry
flannel shirt and just all these people
so what does God have to say about this
well Proverbs 23:7 says for as thinketh
in his heart so is he 1st Samuel 15:23
for Rebellion is as a sin of Witchcraft
in stubbornness is as iniquity and
idolatry because thou Hast rejected the
world of the word of the Lord he hath
also rejected thee from being King
Revelation 129 and the Great Dragon was
cast out that old serpent called the
devil and Satan which deceiveth the
whole world he was cast out into the
Earth and his angels were cast out with
him so that's proof that they're manif
festing or actually walking around
possessing other people
yeah 1 Corinthians uh 6 verse 9-1 know
ye not that the unrighteous shall not
inherit the kingdom of God be not
deceived neither fornicators nor
idolators nor adulterers nor feminite
okay y effeminate nor abusers of
themselves with
mankind nor thieves nor Covetous nor
drunkards nor revilers nor extortioners
shall inherit the kingdom of God
basically that's like everything in a
nutshell yeah that they're doing and
such were some of you but you are washed
but you are Sanctified but you are
justified in the name of Jesus Lord
Jesus and by the spirit of our God
Revelation
218 but the fearful and unbelieving and
of the Abominable and the Abominable the
murderers the whoremongers the sorcerers
and idolators and all liars shall have
their part in the lake which burneth
with fire and brimstone which is a
second death again they're worshiping
Idols these are Gods you're worshiping
yeah they're doing all this
sorcery it's abominable stuff they're
murdering people the sacrifices yeah the
roots of becoming non-binary or uh
whatever transgender is Witchcraft and
so it's I mean it's all covered
effeminate that's covered witchcraft
that's part of it sorcery all this stuff
Liars if you say you're a woman and
you're a man you're a liar yeah and so I
long for the day when we live in a
perfect world where there's no murders
and liars and thieves and and all these
things I want to live in a world like
that yeah and it it amazes me it breaks
my heart that people would give up
eternity just to wear a dress or to have
sex with another
man this there's this world has nothing
to offer that's worth missing out on
eternal life and a perfect world I don't
care how much you think you love that
person right it's not right and it's not
the way God designed
it and I would willingly be celibate if
I had to to have eternal life in God's
kingdom because there's nothing this
world has to offer that that can compare
right um so the last two verses here
then they caused their sons and their
daughters to pass through the fire and
use divination and enchantments and sold
themselves to do evil in the sight of
the Lord to provoke him to anger
Galatians 5:19-21 now the works of the
flesh are manifest which are these
adultery
fornification unclean
uncleanness uh how do you say that
lasciviousness lasciviousness idolatry
witchcraft hatred variance emulations
wrath Strife seditions her heres
envyings murders drunkenness reings and
such like of the which I tell you before
as I have also told you in the past that
they which do such things shall not
inherit the kingdom of God well they're
reveling like it's a party doing all
this yeah yeah let's have a party let's
get intoxicated drunkards will not
adhere the kingdom of
God let's let's get drunk and we're
going to fornicate with every person
there
now you're going to have fornication in
there let's let's say we're female when
we're male now you're a
liar I mean those verses are so
clear and it's just it's not worth it
this lifestyle is not worth it don't
even as a Christian try to justify it
we've we've seen now the roots of where
this comes from this is not acceptable
it's not just an alternative lifestyle
this is witchcraft this is
demonic
worship yeah and it's not going to be
part of God's Kingdom in eternity so
that's yeah like it it actually means
that if you want to have these
Supernatural Powers as they call them
but it's not it's just being able to
speak to Demons or see into the
supernatural demonic world and commune
with them and
stuff they're saying it is a necessity
to be homosexual or lgbtq and do all
these things yeah with everything
animals and everything
alike um that's the power you get and
divination and all this
stuff and so that's spiritual
implication is that you are you're
getting those kinds of powers from Satan
probably money lots of money
too and that's the kind of treasures he
will give you is worldly treasure when
you are blessed by God it's not that
right it
is all of his goodness he gives you
love he gives you I'm I'm kind of
drawing a blank although I understand
that God has lot for us and hope and
eternal life you cannot buy life you
can't it doesn't matter how much money
you have yeah and that's the
thing if you do all these debaucherous
things you might get some some toys in
life oh or millions of dollars yeah but
you're health is going to suffer
your livelihood of life everything
you're under control as well I might add
like we said these people are actually
humiliated publicly they blackmail
always coming at them if they don't do
what the the elites that are controlling
them want you know and and the most most
of all you miss out on eternal life yeah
so these debaucher God doesn't make you
do debaucherous things to get that
greatest gift the greatest gift that
anyone could ever have is eternal life
that's what every person wants every
elest person they if whether they're
doing it through adren Chrome or
whatever they are searching for
immortality and God's the only one that
can give it and he doesn't do it through
disgusting rituals like eating feces and
cutting your genitals off and all these
things he says just give your life to me
because I know what's best for you I
created
who better to go to than the Creator if
I had a car or a computer and it wasn't
working right and I had a chance to talk
to the one who created it I would that's
the person I want to listen to when they
say gasoline goes in the gas tank not
oil not water I'm going to listen to
that person because they made it and
they know how it works I
had something that came to me real quick
and that's when you usually specify your
gender of course you actually like on
the symbol there for men it's the arrow
thing right right for women it's the
cross thing M when you are symbolizing
that androgynous one with just a circle
in the middle you seriously are saying
I'm open to everything and anything I'm
just a big hole to fill right
yeah that's so true yeah I mean symbols
are very meaningful and Powerful and
that's that seems exactly like what it
is MHM so sorry but yeah that's what I
thought of just now and you serious we
are going to miss out on salvation just
for all of this and power of this world
yeah was that the conclusion yes it is
if you guys enjoyed this episode please
give it a thumbs up it really helps this
channel to grow if you're new Please
Subscribe we're going to come up with
videos like this and we're going to talk
about maybe politics and culture and pop
culture and the new Agee all these
different things we want to find out
what's going on in the world what does
the Bible say about what's happening in
our life today sometimes people read the
Bible and they're like it doesn't seem
relevant to me today wow did we see
relevance and what's happening in our
world today with transgender you know
who knew it was in the Bible was in
history it's all all there we want to
search truth and we want to do it with
you and we need we need you we need your
help we need need you to give us ideas
what is on your mind what do you want to
hear about we want to search those
things out and learn together and if you
um if you're new hit subscribe give a
thumbs up share this with your family
and friends especially if you know that
people are struggling with this topic
whether they're in the lifestyle or
supporting the lifestyle both are wrong
and help them to see why that not this
is what we want to do we want to give
the why so often times you're told don't
do this why because I said so or why
because it's bad we want to show you why
and I think I think there's plenty of
evidence given here that this goes all
the way back to the occult and this is
Witchcraft and demonic satanic worship
if you would like to support this
ministry because we can't do it without
you yeah we stepped out in faith to
start this ministry on our own and we
know that God's going to provide if you
want to give to this ministry you can do
so by going to these different things we
have cash app vinmo and zel
um we if you reach out to us we can give
you PayPal or whatever if you want to
get a t-shirt that has our design on it
then you can do so with the link in the
description it takes you to our
Teespring you can represent and you know
it actually helps us too and most of all
we need your prayers and if you want us
to come to your church you can invite us
by going to candid truth.org and then
click on the little link that says
booking and you'll see our calendar we
you'll see that we have uh things lined
up and that churches are inviting us if
you want us to come to your church and
talk about what's wrong with Hollywood
or where these pagan origins of all
kinds of things happen in our life today
then you can book us to come to your
church yeah or any kind of event
actually so we love you we thank you and
we look forward to seeing you next time
on candid truth take care guys